who's gonna control the phone calls will
be phone call person all right switch
this here live YouTube and Facebook
alright what up Twitter what is up
Instagram we're good we're good
hey everybody um thank you so much for
being here with me big day for us as we
are starting to ship empathy wines rose'
and that's what today is about
I'm gonna do a couple things today on
this live session I'm going to first
watch a clip from a LinkedIn post that
is now what have we had 3 million 3.1
million organic reach on LinkedIn one
thing that I keep trying to tell
everybody here is that LinkedIn organic
Reach is through the roof and a lot of
you should be using it and I highly
recommend you be doing more of that I've
been taking my own advice and I've been
doing that and I've been leaning in
pretty heavily and we've been seeing
some real results
what's up Instagram what's up Twitter
YouTube and Facebook so right now what
I'm first gonna do is create some
content while I pour myself some empathy
rose' Nora John and me are here from the
empathy team Nora's deep in the
Instagram comments of the book and
Twitter for the CM irate hooks that I
threw today really excited about it and
this is what we're gonna do I'm gonna
actually do some phone calls but there's
a toll booth for them tonight we'll get
two phone calls later after I do this
LinkedIn post what I'm about to do is
fill myself answering statements or
questions from this very viral post and
you're gonna type in my answers I want
to do more engagement on LinkedIn but I
want more thoughtful engagement but as
you guys see when I reply it's always me
they're very quick and short so now
we're gonna go a little bit deeper
there's a thoughtfulness to LinkedIn so
raghava is gonna read me some of his
favorite comments I'm gonna reply
he's gonna answer we're gonna film it
probably turn it into some more content
very meta and then I'm gonna go into Q&A
here's how you social media
beyond QA today if you go to empathy
wines calm right now and order a case
subscription so that's 720 bucks it's a
case of the Rose a the white and the red
$40 wine for 20 bucks what I think is
the single best deal in wine we've spent
years working on this you can give it as
gifts
you can give it to clients you can use
it for parties but if you go and order
right now on empathy wines calm the case
order subscription those orders will
come in on empathy wines and meat will
die or number and I will answer your
question it's as simple as that
tonight's your night to get your
questions answered you get seven hundred
twenty dollars worth of wine along with
it obviously I think that's a lot of
money so if you don't need the wine
don't drink three cases of wine a year
or don't have a way to give away wine as
clients or gifts then you should
probably not do it though I guess I'm
worth seven hundred twenty bucks for you
think so babbitt thank you but uh but if
you do if you do drink wine at all if
you do buy eight to fifteen dollar wine
they'll jump up to twenty or by the way
if you drink twenty to forty dollar wine
or by the way if you drink whispering
angel we've destroyed whispering angel
that is my plan i don't know if it's
your guys plan they were clipping wings
was what i've been saying
what's going on with the blind tasting
because i know we haven't done i'm not
we need to do more right here's one
thing babban that I would definitely
wanna do with my influence your team we
need to DM more people to come through
the office and film just blind Tate I
expect three people a day just coming
through so let's organize that I really
want to do that look we're gonna give
with spring angel some business and buy
a bunch of bottles I just want blind
taste all day because I know the first
time we empathy won seven out of eight
then the second day was more like three
and three I really want to just go to
like Times Square and just do it go to
jail be viral Instagram what up thank
you so much Twitter thank you so much
for being here Big Ups to everybody you
love you back
big shout out to Facebook and YouTube
let me recap one more time if you're
just joining we're gonna go on actually
I'm going to bring somebody on I like
putting people on on on Instagram on the
live because it updates one one thing
guys that I highly recommend is bringing
people on to your Instagram live because
it updates every time you join somebody
that to the population which makes more
people tune in so I think it's a really
smart move to have people join your live
as a kind of hack for more awareness
that you're online hello
watch my number go from 1651 hello are
you there what up equal eat local meat
and I see tonight she left but I'm back
to 3,600 that's what happens actually
really works what up everybody alright
I'm getting into it we're gonna do the
LinkedIn answers first
then we're gonna do phone calls to
anybody who orders a club empathy and
then if nobody orders a club empathy I'm
gonna just put this corkscrew right
through my [ __ ] eye right up empathy
wine calm Club empathy order it I will
answer your question actually play me
the original clay do this [ __ ] wines
good like that's been like the funniest
part about this whole project is how bad
of a wine me and Trouty in neuro we're
gonna make and then I came to the
blending session late on the flight and
save the day they were about to make
something I mean some fronds a [ __ ] is
your lack of politics yep which means we
are on the dawn of the era where
emotional intelligence yep is about to
become the single most important trade
truth that skills through technology
growth will continue on a daily basis to
be commoditized but your emotional
capabilities to interact with others
will become that a very very important
trade I highly recommend how many people
here have a company with more than 10
people really am
take this one thing away from me you
better go home and audit every single
employee you have and you better figure
out which employee makes the other
employees miserable I don't give a sh
babban fits your number-one salesperson
best developer or your co-founder what
up hammy cancer spreads with cancer and
politics comes lack of one second bug
your company will get much slower
because people are sitting around
debating how miserable they are or
worried to have meetings with other
individuals your company will get slow
in a world where the speed of product
output features and how customers this
is the most real [ __ ] later so I implore
a tech centric financial centric
whatever occasions like this to go home
and get really in tune with the feelings
in my company did you have to add it in
for LinkedIn person is not the CFO
sensor there's a do it automatically are
we gonna excuse me the number two person
after me and it's a good video silver
no wonder [ __ ] three million people
decided fair she's fresh you want
I'm paused it is no question the biggest
variable dies in my cess my pause is
metal think so and I mean ever big more
important for you to care about the s
mr. glazier links culture let me tell
you how I hate to read off build Co
loosen you do not build culture by
having enough free snacks in your
cafeteria let me tell you how you do not
build culture you do not build culture
by having a foosball table or open
seating dude this guy is running culture
by actually talking to people one by one
and understanding what they care about
and what you'll learn is some people
want money yep and some people want time
with their family yep and some people
want title yeah and some people want
this is good [ __ ] it is your job how
many people were to CEO of the company
Twitter what up job to know every single
one of those things about every single
person every single day cuz 23 every
time I don't know I said there's now
we're at a thousand and I don't know I
feel
I'm like listening for this ecosystem
talking to my cell starts and I
recognize the vulnerability elements
that will drive why and who's watching
us right now if you have less than 50
[ __ ] juice with no [ __ ] excuse I
know everything about all of the
opposition that's how I built the
foundation of this decade thank you
that's a beef for that crush all right
now let's get into the feedback you'll
be a push back like a lot of push back
yeah can't wait you're gonna ask me
something bad yes I want some challenges
let's go [ __ ] if you think I'm
[ __ ] scared I don't hear it either
way go ahead yes well when you're ready
any type well first and foremost there's
only one person it could be other than
them and that's you so the reality is
either you are always going to be the
issue and over time you'll realize that
or it's them so whose responsibility is
it their past experiences their parents
their DNA their circumstances or
actually it's you you the owner the boss
like if if this is being asked by
somebody who's a middle manager then
then the whole thing's broken if you
noticed I was talking to the CEO or
owner of the company if you're a middle
manager if you're like an upper manager
if Andy who manages Team Gary has got
the problem that's me or it's you who
works for Andy he's stuck he's in the
middle this video was very specific to
business so notice how I talked over it
just now and said 50 people that's on
you so I'm speaking to business owners
founders or CEOs who have full control
and if it's you that's the problem over
time that will expose itself because
you'll have a revolving door
all right while you're typing that I'll
just engage her a little bit with
Twitter and Instagram baseball
tournament directors are ruining
baseball my dude come on what up
everybody taking questions if you go to
empathy wines calm and order the club
empathy and I will actually ask your
questions so repeating that for
everybody who's just joining if you go
to empathy wines calm right now and
order club empathy I will call you and
answer your question right now zero
order so far couple three packs which I
appreciate thank you so much for
everybody but if you order the case
recurring that is a guaranteed phone
call and if nobody orders the case we
will go to the people who ordered three
packs and call them but guaranteed to
get in before the end of the night if
you order the case subscription the real
question is how many people right now on
Twitter Instagram YouTube and Facebook
by thirty six bottles of wine a year and
the biggest like thing I hear from a lot
of people are Gary I only drink you know
Rosie and red so I don't want to order
the subscription I'm like dude give away
two twelve bottles of white I mean the
math if you just buy the Rose a and it's
seven dollars more right on the three
pack it's 27 what's the six pack 25 like
my thing is like a 27 versus 20 you're
better off just like buying the whole
subscription than buying 27 and 27
how much is 27 times 12 to 40 plus 84
its 332 664 my math is much better than
yours Bannon 664 vs. 720 so the deltas
small
yeah well I guess later on actually it's
480 versus 720 if you wait to the end
guys what we're doing is after
subscriptions are all well after the
wines are all released then you can buy
a mallet cart but for now it's a
subscription
anyway real quick if you go to empathy
wines calm right now and order a case
subscription orders right now we will
call you and answer your question
tonight yeah so I think that's fine uh
you can apply that's fine and I respect
that point of view and it's a sound
point of view a couple things on using
Apple as an example that is where the
founder and CEO was not necessarily the
most culturally awesome person and for
anybody who's that she or he has that
right there are plenty people that have
gone on to build successful businesses
on the back of that however that is also
looking at the past not looking at the
current or the future my big question is
how many of those amazing executives
that change the course of Apple would
have stayed if it wasn't 1991 and 1984
instead of 2018 when the temperature of
our society has clearly changed Thank
You D Rock one of the biggest reasons I
get a lot of pushback is people point to
the past when I'm auditing the current
with anticipating the future the biggest
debate that I have with so many people
in the media world around the housing
thing around my ideas around this Apple
point is what would Steve Jobs
day-to-day look like in today's macro
sure I mean I think yuan Musk is is a
butterfly compared to what year about
Steve Jobs and people have a lot of
cynicism to the way he rolls well what
kind of set of system would be put on
Steve Jobs in today's environment that's
like saying like you know think about
all the cultural things we accepted in
1964 that we don't accept today thank
you
we've got a cold water well let's call
that person they deserve it right away
club orders coming through you're
getting phone calls first then jumping
building thin anybody who's out on three
pack subscriptions right now thank you
very much we'll get to you next if we
don't have that many call borders we're
getting some of those three pack waters
right please enjoy did you arrive and
rain back down while your party is free
[Applause]
or during a three pack means the world
to me hello hello James this is Gary
Vaynerchuk from empathy wines and I want
to thank you from the bottom of my heart
for your club empathy subscription hey
Gary you know what man I just love
everything you got going on and first of
all I wouldn't reduce myself
I'm crystals it's off baby brother I
apologize to cut off on me one more time
you whose baby brother you I'm great
those the top ski it's baby brother get
out of town that's amazing it's a real
pleasure brother hey man
I guess that tell you man like it the
pleasure's all mine you know I just love
that like my heart's beating like like
from here at the moon right now like I
just uh
you know I've been doing my business now
for 16 years and I just celebrated
sixteen years last month and like you
know just you know heaven my dailyvee
every day kind of gets me through
everything I just want to thank you for
that uh-huh
you know one of the things that I love
the most is when when you when you share
your story about the Jets sweater and in
first grade I wanted to be Hulk Hulk
Hogan and my mom actually made my Hulk
Hogan costume instead of buying it for
me and you know so it's just a lot of
silhouettes the molarity and you know
like I said I'm not gonna lie I'm just
like really nervous right now talk more
you're not gonna lie I'm super flattered
don't even worry like get unnerved you
know I don't mean [ __ ] you know
so you know what you you you know uh
it's just a lot of similarities you know
my parents are off the boat
my mom my dad's from Macedonia my mom's
from Greece state you know their
villages are uh you know an hour and a
half apart but yeah if they met in
Rochester New York and that's amazing
I'm myself and my brother are the
byproduct of my grandparents and my
parents and and and and it's just so
cool that I share a lot of similarities
like with someone like you let yourself
you know and invite the birthday and
Prince um is there anything on the phone
um I'll be honest with you um you asked
a lot of my daily questions all the time
and I have a million questions for you
but at this moment I can't even think
one I'm not gonna lie um send me an
email if something pops up you know it's
funny I talk often about like giving
without expectation and like all the
content I put out all this like Nate
trout inor and I we have 24,000 cases to
sell of this wine we've sold like six
thousand five thousand we have 25,000
cases to sell we've been pushing hard
for four months and we sold 5000 so you
can imagine it's such an uphill battle
right like I'm in a place in my career
where like sitting here for the next
three hours trying to sell a couple
cases here and there like I'm putting in
the work and so like even though you
give a lot like the level of gratitude I
have brother James like the level of
gratitude I have right now that you
bought these three cases means the world
to me I mean it like I think people are
very confused about what it means to
live in the dirt like I still live in
the dirt my ambitions are in the clouds
but I sit here tonight on a Monday night
and 9:22 p.m. with like in a lot of
people's eyes the world in my hands and
I'm sitting here hustling to sell wine
to provide value to answer questions
you'd be stunned as much as you're
nervous to talk to me if you felt the
warmth in my soul right this second bro
I've been online for about 15 minutes I
put out the most content engage the most
do the most all for free and you're the
only person so far that has ordered a
club empathy for the time couple that
are watching I could I could I couldn't
I couldn't do it fast enough man you
know and they call me Jimmy Z and that's
my restaurants name is Jimmy Z's it's in
Brockport New York and that
just in you know and like I said 16
years to grind and you know my can third
generation in the business and you know
and like I said just I I spoke where I'm
in the I'm in a college town and I spoke
to these kids I'm like 16 years ago I
was doing this to spread the name and
now I said how many people here didn't
know who I was before I walked in here
and only one hand raised that didn't
know who I was and I said but I'm still
here even though you guys know who I am
because because you guys there's people
that gave me the opportunity to make it
this far and now it's my Duty's my civil
duty just to know to teach you
everything that I thought into the same
person that took their time and the time
you take every day bro uh you know I
love you for that and you know what man
I have like I said I'd love to drop you
an email you know please yeah and you
know go ahead I appreciate it man thank
you so much it really it means a lot to
me it really does and by the way like
like what's most exciting about this is
like the wine people are gonna give it
to people first of all the Rose a thing
is huge for me because I think we made
the best Rose a so I think our worlds
about to change next week when people
start eating it so I'm not giving away
the Rose Day because that's my favorite
the line is don't matter than the white
the red the red and the whites gonna go
but yeah man I I had I had an awesome
documentary made for the 16 year
anniversary and got a lot of a lot of
local flavor hopefully I think I'm gonna
email I want to email you a link to that
hopefully they have 23 minutes to watch
it that would mean the world to me and
people that do one day [ __ ] 5,000
cases of club empathy for 23 minutes
Rock watch it and then he'll give me the
cliff notes listen that's fine and
hopefully one day we can watch the Jets
game together and drink some beers in
New York I love it brother thank you so
much take care thank you by the way I
also want to say this cuz its caveat for
as much of like the sob story and like
the guilt trip of this I I mean this
with the bottom my heart if you don't
drink three cases of wine if you can't
figure out how to give it away if you
like have no use for it seven or twenty
bucks a lot of money I expect everybody
should be pouring that back into their
own businesses you know by the rocks kit
that he promotes super well like you
should be doing whatever you want that's
best for you at uh I love life so much
point being that was
more of a shout out for d-roc skin and a
brass boat it was like an amazing
feeling anyone twice
I don't expect [ __ ] it's unbelievable
like living without expectations
unbelievable but if you buy three cases
of wine a year that's between 15 if it's
even 15 because I'll take that Delta on
the five bucks at like [ __ ] Costco
like if you're buying your [ __ ] wine
at Albertsons and you're buying $20
horseshit I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you if
you don't sign up a club empathy if you
somehow have consumed the [ __ ] load of
my content for free and equally buy $20
$15 $22 $27 horseshit that [ __ ] BevMo
or total wine and you're not buying Club
empathy you're a [ __ ] dick face raagh
off let me answer a question and Nate
Hammond what are we getting some Club
entities now oh really
the plea worked I love you guys so much
go ahead let me answer some LinkedIn
then we'll bounce at guys on a serious
note and I'm pumped because a buncha
just ordered means the world to me we're
going to by the way at this point I
would probably not order three bottles
if you expect to get in the queue
because enough Club empathise are coming
in that's gonna take me too long yeah 14
people I've got two more hours here
between answering LinkedIn and being
long-winded I don't want to [ __ ]
anybody do not order three bottles
anymore if you're expecting to get in to
the calls we're gonna only do the calls
but I'm gonna get to everybody who buys
Club empathy if you're buying three
cases tonight I'm [ __ ] calling you so
but real quick on no [ __ ] we made a
[ __ ] rose a that people like I think
by the way if you bought it in a bunch
about prior please share your tasting
notes on video next week or this week
we're shipping a thousand orders
tomorrow but tomorrow thousand yeah what
video
no you guys made a video yeah you post
on social call should watch it yeah it's
pretty good for these [ __ ] isn't that
ready okay good does he have it oh okay
let's go
I got a sip it like 10 more times to
even be sure well I gotta watch this
do you rock I mean John come on you suck
that's what are you doing alright guys
you're seeing it first you can't really
see it huh you know obviously it is
pretty during the summer but it's great
all the time if you ask me I do like
wine I like it a lot as I get older I
appreciate it more more on the sweet
side also more bubbly the biggest the
biggest one is that it has to be really
cheap and it has to be this goes out
tomorrow oops America's number one
anyone going to it's gorgeous number one
that's a lot Pinker thank you so much
thank you like what more like a peach
and I'd say this one's more of like a
pinky sort of color this looks more like
the type that I'm used to drinking so
we'll see if it tastes a little bit
better than that that guy all the way in
the glass right because I learned this
during the video last week oh that's
Pleasant it was just more obviously
fruitier it's like more explosive he did
not write more in your face like in
smell wise we [ __ ] made a good
washing
it smells kind of literally really fresh
I'm a little bit nervous now we do in
the white blend Thursday buying the six
now King Boris it's only 12
don't buy sex Oh hammy TV Lanigan love
you hammy like it matches the colour you
know I would expect that from this yeah
like cranberry cherry there's almost
like like a jolly rancher excess quality
ah my Labradoodle change the game just
to like like the tannins already a very
naturally selected person so now I'm
just kind of like I got a sip it like 10
more times to even be sure back to make
those bird sounds so you just make bird
sounds when you not too sweet but sweet
enough Thank You Mac be more slowly I
like this guy right here
I could definitely drink both on a
Sunday Funday Rose a day probably
repurchase like a case of this one
preference between the two I would say
the dinner wine because I'm just be huge
dinner person I'm a huge foodie
I had to pick a preference just because
two has more personality and more
there's more in there nice trout he was
so pumped fruity and dryer and that's
just my personal taste
I knew it I know it whispering angel she
picked my spring angel see
[Music]
she picked she's so awesome too she's so
awesome
she picked whispering angel why I have
to watch her hole footage oh good for
her good for her all right
LinkedIn all right let me catch up
everybody YouTube Facebook Instagram
Twitter thank you for being here with me
tonight gonna be on for another two
hours tell your friends share the videos
share share share share share we are
answering people's questions if you
order Club empathy the three cases one
of rose' one of white wanna bread on
reorder how many orders we add to that
right now 15 to 20 so we have a bunch of
phone calls to get to we're also
answering a viral post on LinkedIn that
got three million views I just watched
the video earlier if you're catching
late I'm answering questions about
company culture and we're answering
questions rogoff's answering for me in
the comments which we do sometimes you
know I just think about my I think you
if you're answering it for interview
purposes you speaker truth and I would
give it an answer that both shows when
you did it well and once that showed
that it didn't do well I think
interviewers and people in companies are
starting to really enjoy truth and the
reality is people are so full of [ __ ] in
the interview process and there's a
complete PR version of themselves I'm
looking at everybody here who I hired
they were all full of [ __ ]
unlike what they said in the interview
process they just like I'm just kidding
first of all I didn't hire everybody
second of all like I never care I just
go on gut but most places love the value
of somebody speaking their truth and
value that and so I would give an answer
of when you've done it well and when you
haven't done it well on the conflict
front I think that you want to get hired
by somebody who's not scared of you
saying when you drop the ball I love
that I love that what happened to RAM
can you people update me on what's going
on with the international people are
asked about UK Canada just like let's
shoot it straight where are we in the
international place right Australia New
Zealand Singapore big news for you vino
mofo VI n o mo fo dot-com is going to be
the exclusive provider of empathy that's
right if you're watching right now from
Singapore Australia or New Zealand what
are those like 12 hours ahead usually
like so it's in the morning great news
New Zealand Australia in Dhoni Singapore
are gonna be three of the markets that
are gonna have it first we're shipping
containers there now or soon soon
they're doing they were vino mofos CEO
was here we filmed together so Australia
New Zealand and Singapore vino mofo
dot-com is gonna be one of the few
places in the world with empathy I'm
fired up about it
get ready for that next can i stuff
we're hacking we're submitting like if
everything went perfect Canada's what
January oh really
shipping direct from us with a high cost
or through their stores or consignment
okay next we have no solution for UK
Europe so look if you're watching and
you're an entrepreneur right now and
it's late suck it's like five hours yeah
it's like 2:00 in the morning but like
nonetheless if you happen to be in UK or
Europe and you have a way to buy a
thousand cases we'll give you a deal
obviously and you want to be the
purveyor in Germany in London in all of
Europe
ruch you know whatever it is this is a
huge opportunity to collaborate so if
you're a business you have to be a big
[ __ ] business but you know like if
you're a huge retailer in the UK and you
happen to be watching right now let's
see yeah like you never know like stuff
travels somebody can clip this and
forward it to who berry Brothers or you
know just a supermarket chain or who the
[ __ ] knows people are smart like
entrepreneurs are smart somebody be
really smart to email me Gary at
vaynermedia calm on a thousand case
order in a country we'll figure it out
if you want to get ridiculous if you're
a billionaire and you're watching and
you want it exclusively for your I met a
billionaire the other day they're like
owns amazing Hotel in like Grenada and I
was like he's watching right now you
want some thousand cases for his hotel
in Grenada like talk to me thousand
cases and you're in the mix all right
let's call
we have a secret canned project right ii
happen it's secret we have a lot of
sugar justin dry gave me some love hello
hello Beth
hey Gary Beth azor commercial real
estate South Florida I know who you are
Beth you're the best I [ __ ] love you
thank you so much for supporting this it
means a lot are you giving this as gifts
yeah I need to talk to Nate this last
order I need to send someone else when I
didn't you know I was doing it fast so I
didn't want to put them all under a pile
of you anything I can answer for you
well I got you yeah quick get the noose
DMVs how many of what percentage of them
are going to open bricks and mortar
obviously that's important in my world I
apologize one more time digital native
brands what percentage are gonna open
bricks and mortar a ton if I'm you I'm
following TechCrunch and recode and
seeing every direct consumer brand that
has raised the series see which means
they're probably getting between 40 30
50 60 70 million in cash
yeah and I'm literally emailing them
saying if you want to expand into retail
every EPC brand when it hits scale
becomes like Warby Parker and starts
thinking about actual retail after
they've saturated the internet and
Amazon so look for Series C funded
consumer packaged good dtc brands I
think you'll find an enormous
fruitfulness fabulous alright guys good
luck the rest of the night you're the
best Beth thank you for your support all
right fine she's amazing what's the one
more call and then we'll get the rag off
let me update Instagram Twitter YouTube
and Facebook if you go to empathy wines
dunk on right now in order club empathy
that's a case of each of the rows a
white and right we haven't even talked
about the concierge service that comes
off and club after nine getting hit it
up or people are still like tanner
it's it's delayed a little bit in Texas
right hello look Tanner Tanner its Gary
Vaynerchuk
what's up GERD how are you life is good
brother thank you so much for the
support it means the world to me
no problem I uh I bought it the last
time you threw the right hook and the
last time we met it was in Dallas about
three years ago
when I traded you some Cowboys tickets
for ten minutes of your time dude that
was the [ __ ] best bro I remember that
like yesterday I really appreciate that
I was with my mom and dad and your
payday and AJ and I remember you like
yesterday it's great to connect again
and I can't thank you enough for
supporting this project it means the
world to me anytime you know whenever we
spoke then I was talking about wanting
to put my art on wine labels and I said
you know I actually I have that video
and then I just put it out on YouTube
actually today of me and you talking
about that but I'm also pitching empathy
wines putting my heart switch now I'm
getting you know twenty thirty forty
thousand for my horse paintings and I
would love to do a little oh and it's
and me since we met we met December 2015
and I was doing about a hundred thousand
cells on my on my paintings at the time
and last year I did over 650,000 my
loans
anything you would tribute to the best
man I went all-in on me you know I my
gallery we were doing bad when I was
trying to represent a bunch of artists
and I just couldn't keep up because I
was pretty much a one-man shop maybe two
men you know I mean I had one one
part-time guy I guess but then my
partner my business partner left because
he started losing money after he made
all his money and he left and so I went
all in on me I invested my last ten
grand of credit card you know into the
business into a show in New York
actually which I'll be in New York next
week for one of my big shows and
honestly I've crushed it every single
show since then or I'm selling you know
60 to 85 percent of my inventory each
Joe you know and you know I just I'm
working them at the gallery right now
putting in time put the kids to bed we
talked about you know spending time with
her family and make sure there's quality
time and you know and it's just made the
world of difference you know I've been
having lunch with my daughter every week
at school at least once a week for the
last three years since we met and you
know I guess you basically went in all
in on your own art go in on your own
family
stop worrying going outside and 6x2 your
business exactly exactly and and now I'm
I'm coming back to I'm actually going to
see you this Friday in Dallas about one
of the elite ticket package someone hear
you speak Friday night be my first time
here in person and but I'll be in New
York next thing for my big show and I
was looking into if I'm around send me
an email right now - Gary of vaynermedia
and if you okay round stop by I'd love
to like hug it out yeah that'd be great
and I got a piece of art that did you
ever get my jet helmet from last time I
don't want to [ __ ] you I'm not sure
but we will figure that out come through
go through let's take a photo I want to
give you love on my social this is this
is what I'm about right you just spent
seven hundred twenty bucks and it means
so much to me that when you come through
we're gonna take a photo and I'm gonna
do a swipe up to your gallery in my
story and you're gonna get seventy two
thousand in value in return
that's just was gonna have it it's that
bit I tell you I'm actually thinking
about dropping ten to fifteen with you
for the four DS because we'll be there
most of that day that's at the end of my
show and I actually want to come you'd
give you even more because I know it's
worth it you know and you've been great
we start our YouTube channel you're
gonna love this in the far back right
now showing these cameras Nick do who
runs sales for four days and Sasha is
like in the back going wild right now
this is the best I [ __ ] love sales I'm
not you know what we're I'm gonna retire
and just sit on live on the internet
selling and hanging out 18 hours a day
[ __ ] I'm going all in on me see how
the media I'm just gonna be me dude I'm
proud of you
I can't wait to see you when are you
coming what are you gonna be here my
shell is I get in town next Tuesday a
week from tomorrow and then I'll be
Tuesday and Wednesday and then I may not
be Thursday and Friday so let's figure
that out okay some unis my job I still
got your I still got your number I've
never used it you know that's a people
app way way way better to email me at
Gary vaynermedia because my admins are
in there and then this week okay they'll
handle it yeah okay done well and I
won't let you know what I'm doing just
for the thousands that are watching
right now what's your URL tier art my my
name is Tanner Lally my gallery is the
Lally art group group that's t th e la
WL e Y art group.com and like I said we
just started YouTube channel I've got
the video of how to get ten minutes when
Gary B is the name of my video and talks
about my barter how we did it I've got
the picture of the painting that you won
because of the bet that we had about the
score and you know it was just yeah
y'all didn't understand and and I tell
you one thing I last thing real quick
and but you know I don't I have an
allergy to the alcohol so I don't even
drink and I start breaking out in hives
and stuff but just let you know I've now
I bought last time you pitch like the
240 or the 83 dollar version and then
now I've added this on top but we're
doing third Thursday's here and aren't
walk in the Design District and I'm
going to showcase your wines and serve
your wines and give it out to all my
customers on the third Thursday of every
month this year at my gallery so I'm
really pleased with it so much no
problem thank you thanks for you man but
let's do one LinkedIn let's do one
empathy if you're just joining us now
we're answering questions and comments
from the three million organic reach on
LinkedIn on a post
I keep telling all of you figure out how
to get your content on LinkedIn and also
we're selling empathy wines my new
winery if you go to empathy wines calm
and order the club empathy which is a
case of each you will then get a phone
call from me how many have we beginning
some orders or
yeah we got it that big blast when I
kind of got sad in that one moment right
that really that's like that QVC [ __ ]
right where I felt where everyone felt
guilty when I said he was the only one
that buys and you know yeah okay raagh
up it's just the wildest session yeah
fire the ones that lack that was
qualities let me say ready reply let me
say it loud and clear
fire cancer the person you're describing
is not cancer the entitled people
underneath that person are the cancer PS
I'm about to file three or four people
fire three or four people that I think
are lovely I just think they're entitled
and not and and that's the problem
hey what up Twitter just want to speak
to you guys directly Twitter directly
right now Matt what up doll off to what
up J green I would a holistic dad would
up now go to Instagram what up Apple
what up D heart what up Jodi surf selfie
hello Joe J what up Harry what's your
name hey Jordan Jordan its Gary
Vaynerchuk how are you oh my god who's
awesome
I'm doing great no what's awesome is I
can't thank you enough from the bottom
of my heart for supporting empathy and
ordering these three cases what are you
gonna do with them probably admit you
know some gifts share them with family
and friends I'm a doctor I have lots of
doctor friends who need to be turn to
turn onto this so I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna share thank you brother I
appreciate it
what can I answer for you you know it's
interesting I've been connected to your
story for a long time because I pay my
way through med school by flipping
things by going on Craigslist and
getting free stuff in this guy and
hustling during it was crazy and if my
best score
and thousand later that's what gets me
going best scores a garage sales yes go
cuz I'm getting I like you just didn't
alright like you just fired me the [ __ ]
up go it so here's the story
Craigslist a guy's moving the next day
says his wife needs him to move three
thousand laser discs you know what a
laser disc is right the [ __ ] they're
like 20 to 80 to 200 bucks a pop on eBay
yeah exactly so Anna most of us my
Kurian collection their criterion
collection which is like it's just the
high-end stuff I bumper of my Honda
Civic DX was scraping the ground cause
she's things are so heavy but I ran over
to his house and jammed them all into my
car and I ran her how much he wanted a
case of water and then gone within an
hour
it cost me five bucks to get the case of
water on clearance at like the shop
right and then I immediately went into
eBay and started putting them on I said
and this is how I you know don't use the
term reverse engineer I found a guy on
eBay who had the most listings private
messaged him and said by the lot like I
scraped out high-end ones and serve
those individually but about 2,500 of
them I shipped to one guy for about four
bucks apiece and it was the best score
ever had I'm invincible I'm something
like Spanky I can't really on your five
year investment by focusing on
Craigslist and knowing about laserdiscs
you turned up five bucks into how much
so you're doing this listen you got a
thousand for the one-off that's right
and for the other and 100 it was it was
about a 758 bit because I'm going to
quick turnaround so it was about 850 in
per laser discs I think I actually five
thousand for your $5 yes I think I think
it was just over six thousand when I
calculated all of it all of it and I
rolled it into my next thing which was
buying stuff in that you know in Banana
Republic at ninety percent off and then
my buddy's sneaker store was going out
of business and I bought all of his
leftover inventory flip his eight-six
kaya knows that I bought
there's a show idea I've been pitching
like like like I've been trying to think
about like what I want to do on
television if anything yeah and I keep
this idea where I want to go up against
like like two of the sharks from shark
tank and like from like the Prophet like
I'll get like ten prominent
businesspeople and do like a survivor
thing where we all go under like eight
hours of makeup look nothing like
ourselves then get a $10 get dropped in
a random town and have 24 hours to make
the most money I love it I absolutely
love it so here's my thing right like I
still have energy and when I saw it
brought me back like you know there's a
lot of people out there so I swear
between no offense between you and
looking at some other stuff out there
but when you started to do that start
doing that uh you know doing the garage
sales again man it brought you back
Emily will come that I work at a really
I live in Boston I work at a really good
institution here in boss and I've had a
great career [ __ ] doctor in Boston now
right grime in your [ __ ] life oh man
I love it how do i how do I get how do I
get that because you know what you're
doing right now I'm like literally
singing here I'm like [ __ ] I gotta get
to Boston and sign all the bottles of
empathy for him just so he flips them as
a collector like I love it oh man I
could beat this all day long they're
like I'm probably like only a week or
two away maybe three from bringing back
trash talk cuz it's almost garage sales
season here so yeah like I'm getting
have you watched any there's three
episodes have you seen it yet yes I saw
I think I don't know if it was one or
two but I saw I definitely saw I call
one of them I [ __ ] can't wait yeah I
mean it's just emphasis you know and you
know what week and that's sort of in my
usually DNA like I started watching some
some others what another show and you
were on that and we're kind of going
back and forth what's a DNA or not it do
you have it yeah that's a part of me but
I one thing is is it just always
something just is gonna become aside it
doesn't really fit in my day job and I
kind of feel like I'm an outsider where
I work because when I talk to other
people about this like nobody has it and
I'm not and I mean it like they're super
academic and Grill
oh dear man I know edit or it's hard
because you're so many offers with my
doctor man
okay it's uh you know my wife's I Drive
her you're like I was really good
Wow yeah of course yeah cuz you know
she'll come home I've got a secret
closet and you want to find [ __ ] in
there every now and again you're doing
it again
you're a collector at heart huh no no no
it you know what there are certain
things I like to collect side Month
right like but that's what for me it's
the arbitrage I love seeing something
that other people don't you see lucky to
have a ha honestly you need to convert
it into your hobby like honestly I love
business I love my family
then I love the New York Jets then I
loved garage saling then I love my
business and you need to make like
flipping like your true hobby some
people like to find ski yeah people like
to go to museums or like I don't care
like I hate call yeah everything like
[ __ ] all I want to do is buy mug for
a [ __ ] quarter and sell it for 850 on
[ __ ] you know eBay like that's what
it's like if you told me I could find
[ __ ] eight six thousand dollars worth
of laser discs for five bucks or hit
Siberian ones consecutively that were
documented on video I would take the
piss and you put put the other thing
that I in or not in all seriousness
because what I'm just the reality of the
brand I can probably take over to
culture for an hour I'll let you go no
but I thank you friend awesome I know
weird one for you I got a weird one for
you I want to know for you to go on an
episode of trash talk with me this
summer one son sell me there right now
in the title be like I'm the doctor
who's gonna be on trash left by the way
for everybody watching we know how to
figure out you're not the actual Daleks
or every time we do this so don't be a
dick so anyway just email me and say I'm
the doctor
we'll figure it out you're gonna be on
an episode
it's gonna be awesome we're gonna start
the IKEA wait with this clip and then
you're just gonna be in the car and
we're just gonna find [ __ ] I love it I
can't wait talk to you about all right
take care thank you alright Rob leave
I'll give you I'll give you like that's
all I want you to reply to me give me
the next one like many more people
should be leaving their jobs a lot of
people like oh I've been at this job for
7 years if I leave now I've given it all
up I'm wasting time I'm wasting
everything you're not wasting it staying
in a cancer filled environment is
wasting time when it's a dead end it's a
dead end
you staying longer doesn't change it
being a dead end you leaving and
starting over with the experiences and
things you've learned is being on the
offense not giving up so many people are
in these abusive business relationships
where they don't want to leave because
they think they've given up all the time
they put in that's like abusive that's
the framework of the abuse of nature of
it you need to [ __ ] leave that was
one [ __ ] word to your question Raghav
give me one more question then we'll go
to me yes give me in the next one yes I
believe that a lot of informations being
commoditized and emotional intelligence
is on the growth are they the boss
first you have to find out if your ego
is speaking or if you're speaking on
merit I mean I think too many bosses
come from a place of ego which is
actually insecurity hidden and like
you're giving feedback as a weapon and
before I even answer this question you
have to ask yourself are you giving that
feedback to protect yourself or propel
yourself or is it your honest
merit-based feedback
my biggest cynicism is managers feedback
on employees because I feel like they're
protecting their mode you know Nate and
trout were my inner circle you know it's
funny both of them just react reacted I
was just watching both men they both
just reacted and it's because they were
on Team Garrett they were on my internal
like office of the CEO right like and we
dealt with people's stuff and they know
that my cynicism for the most senior
it's funny people at vaynermedia think
that if they complain about their boss
they're gonna get fired it's actually
the reverse I actually almost always
believe that managers like if I don't
know if I can't figure it out after like
real investigation I'm always gonna go
with the employee not the manager
manager has more to lose everybody
thinks it's the reverse I don't
I think bad behavior comes when you have
something to lose
alright go ahead to remind everybody in
Cirebon
Twitter Facebook and YouTube thank you
so much for being on if you order a club
empathy empathy wines calm and a case of
each I'm calling you tonight and I'm
gonna get drunk but this Rose is like so
drinkable that's the problem Gary Gary
Vee hello hello Andrew how are you
please I'm doing great man I'm doing
great
what are you to do with the wine just
ordered I'm gonna get it man I love them
I'm good I'm gonna give it a give it
away individually in the right occasion
you're the best bro where do you live I
just moved to New York actually three
months ago man you may remember we
played we played ball together at a of
who's that we're at a.m. who picked a
involved I do recall that word in you oh
yes I know exactly who you are dude dude
you're [ __ ] crappy I appreciate that
I'm excited we have the tournament this
Thursday I was at 39 picked out of 40
and honestly I kind of feel good about
it you have nowhere to go but up one of
me you were 39 at 40 yeah didn't you
hear about what happened my ankle and
foot I did I was extremely disappointed
and I told AJ I recommend this thing
called voodoo floss it you wrap it
around your ankle you do some ability
drills it gets rid of scar tissue and
inflammation I don't think I've ever
respected more I've never respected AJ
more than this moment the fact that he
didn't pass that on to me because he
probably wants me to be worse going
forward I've never been more proud of my
brother
AJ's Christ dude good good
AJ's basketball like and I take a
substantial amount of credit for how
good he is given like how he made you do
Troy he was he's good actually
all I do it the way you talked about him
and I expected the way be way worse but
he is well he's solid no you can play he
can play
I'm on the other hand old and finished
and now I have a broken ankle and now
I'm [ __ ] really in trouble I'm sorry
about that you should never land under
the shooter oh I was pretty annoyed
right all right
do you see the [ __ ] video how hurt I
was I did I actually had my check-in
this morning the one month
he's happy with the way it's progressing
so I should be back in a month or two
well Matt hey can I do anything for you
dude I really like you I'm really glad
you called
I obviously we've been matched up
against each other every time when we
played so it makes me hate you but I
like the way you play I just have to
give my best
then basketballs not the sport that most
talented at but there's something about
that you know I grew up playing soccer
so like I don't know I love the
challenge behind it but it was a point
moment were we playing where I like had
a good play and you came back down the
other way and scored and I really
respected the [ __ ] out of it appreciate
that let me tell you my story real quick
so I moved to New York for to join a
start-up about three months ago and back
to like that toxic culture I never liked
to talk poorly about another culture but
it just wasn't a fit and just to three
weeks ago I got laid off surprisingly
I'm in sales business development yeah
sending my numbers doing well
but we were just wasn't a culture fit
I'd love the opportunity to get into
your ecosystem which is pretty bad and I
just want to know how I go about that
well it's funny five minutes ago I was
like I need a salesperson for my world
like literally before we went on live I
was like the biggest thing I'm missing
right now is I just want a sales culture
because we're all about branding content
and I was like [ __ ] if we had a sales
person for the last five months on
empathy wine we'd be at 10,000 cases
instead of 5,000 so dude listen honestly
indepen I do put a little prospecting
cold calling right now dude honestly
this is super serendipitous like I you
really caught my attention the way you
played basketball literally Nate right
now sitting literally Nate sitting here
right now this is a real story
I just want I'm like moving the cameras
yeah Nate there is an article we'll post
it bro I'm not kidding this is a real
story Nate who is my partner who owns
equity and empathy whines literally has
his job today
God his solidified job at vaynermedia
and is literally my partner he's my
partner not my employee in empathy were
mate thank you right wait bro you're
gonna like this story even better he got
it because I liked the way he played
volleyball when he was an intern at
vaynermedia's first year off-site in
Vermont hey I think there's a lot of
metaphors to it like if you graduate
four years ago called like it or not
you're always being evaluated and it
like it's on Google that right now for
everybody was watching literally it's
the story of me which is he just thought
he was a young intern playing volleyball
I liked his gusto decided to fully
employ him as my admin and it started
the course of his career which led to
nine years later him being an owner II
of my owner of a winery that's real life
Nate how old are you he's [ __ ] 30
he's a [ __ ] kid he was just a [ __ ]
[ __ ] intern that's a [ __ ]
company but he tried hard and volleyball
and at 30 wait a minute you were 29 you
started his company what did he [ __ ]
nine he owned a winery like that's real
[ __ ] and after we [ __ ] sell some of
the [ __ ] he's gonna make real money he's
gonna be a [ __ ] millionaire and part
of a country club cuz he's a [ __ ]
scratch golfer and he's gonna [ __ ]
love life all because he [ __ ] tried
during volleyball and I'm not kidding
bro I wouldn't [ __ ] you you can see
how I'm reacting and I know that we've
had the interactions on the court I like
the way you play basketball I appreciate
that I'm 29 I'm going on 30
congratu congratulations man send me an
email there's literally Gary at
vaynermedia
I'll see you next week we're gonna hack
I appreciate it so much Gary thank you
bro talk to you see this is what I love
about life look if you just pay if
you're smart enough to pay to everything
like it's like it's a one big game of
karma you just got laid off but he's
still pulling up 720 and he's like like
he seems like the kind of kid that
probably made a buck or two but like
after the volleyball do you remember how
intense that was tell everybody tell
everybody Nate like come over like you
sit here and you tell the story to the
[ __ ] volleyball it's a little like
what you learned about me that day no
but like really play it out vaynermedia
I interned at Cork a wine social media
blog at a time and we're supposed to be
the day of like many bid was
team-building yep but it was like a
competition you were there trout what
like travel was there and different
active route was good at volleyball -
and then volleyball came out volleyball
tournament we played for eight hours
eight hours played eight hours of out of
a maybe one water break eight hours yeah
I was upset about that one break I was
well we went up against John OHS I was
on John Oates was six [ __ ] nine the
senator from Boston College like just
standing him all right all right you
rock the seeds that's the seed they are
in that region D rocks asking about the
tournament right now have you guys
started to be filled out your brackets
you saw the email do you not understand
how severe it was
that's all there you definitely got the
email if you have a vaynermedia [ __ ]
email Bab and come on
thank you tell him guys didn't the
bracket the n-c-double-a tournament a
big deal at Vayner yes they're the best
few minutes you'll notice there's four
ones I got
34% of 12 seeds have won against the
five seed in the last five years
all right let's do some more phone calls
actually one more from you run you die
late but you could be a really maybe
they need support maybe they feel
overwhelming pressure to keep the
performance I couldn't agree more
now the question is now the question is
after they fail again you have to ask
yourself are you valuing the finances
over your culture people come up with
all sorts of justifications for the
person that's bringing money of why
they're a [ __ ] that's what I'm
concerned about
got it yeah I'm good
remind everybody is trying to divine
order clock empathy which is a case of H
of empathy vines calm my new winery the
rosing shipping this week and we will
call you how many more to be up okay
hello hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk Cory how
are you I'm good how are you dude i'm
super well man thank you so much for
supporting this project yeah that's the
only reason I did it I just wanted to
support I appreciate them in you have
any idea what you're gonna do with the
wine I want to drink it yeah that's the
[ __ ] answer tell you about yourself
yeah yeah I'm tuning in and out of your
live stream and the rate at which you're
refilling your glass has been real good
about my investment yeah it's it's super
weird man like it's super funny like I'm
subconsciously like living out what my
thesis was and and I we filmed our right
we filmed the blending I think when you
guys see the real blending like the
thing I was pushing in the room like
what's really great is that like Nora I
was really super impressed with your
palette by the way I was paying very
close attention trotty's got a really
good palette made solid or solid but
like yeah you like good wine but like it
was interesting Nora and Jon or
especially I thought was really strong
and obviously the winemakers and John
had some really good put like it was
really a great session but I remember
like trying to not get caught up in
making the best wine for the 1% of the
1% of the wine world and making the best
wine for the 99% of people that are
actually gonna drink it and I got to
tell you I'm feeling awfully confident
that we made the most delicious [ __ ]
rose' in the world I really believe that
I love it we're playing that retro they
we're blending the white on Thursday I'm
going to San Francisco on Thursday and
we're gonna blend the white on Thursday
nice anything I can answer for you
brother no I honestly don't have any
questions I've been watching one to
support I was literally on my way to Fez
mo you made a comment about it like
alright I gotta buy this I've been
looking to do it it's just kind of you
know actually getting getting on the
site and putting my credit card info in
and doing it dude that's thank you so
much for that bro
see Gordon this is the thing that's
pissing me off there are thousands of
people watching that are literally on
their way to [ __ ] bed mo and total
wine to buy [ __ ] wine I mean that
could buy like a fifteen dollar wine I
want to say [ __ ] it's gonna be super
fine and that 15 to 20 dollar wine is
gonna be worth fifteen to twenty eight
nine seventeen even occasionally twenty
three but I went out and leveraged all
my power in the wine business to make
$40 wine for 20 bucks and these people
are watching every day free content I
feel like should win this game I agree
yeah do what you do four months ago well
it's like one day in the future you know
like we're shipping the Roseate this
week like you'll get instant
gratification unless you're in Texas
which is brand no I'm in Seattle so yes
I gotta sell you this song I listen to
your podcast I hear the you know your
pitch every day and I'm like yeah I do
drink wine I should try it by sector
that but I don't know this is why but I
did it bro this is why I push everybody
to give without expectations right
you're such a good dude I can tell by
the vibe you can sue my conscience every
day you
you buy wine from [ __ ] BevMo and yet
here we are five months later and you
haven't bought the wine if he dress
right you don't give without
expectations humans will let you down
and then you'll be set right yeah yeah
there's a only identify I was in Cory's
watching right now who still haven't
bought it
they're literally watching right now
literally tomorrow they're gonna go to
Albertsons or Publix or [ __ ] BJ's or
Costco or [ __ ] Wine Library and buy
some [ __ ] wine and yet here I am
with empathy forty they got to do it
like I said just look at the rate at
which you're refilling your glass like
that really honestly I think we sell
5000 subscriptions in the next 30 to 60
days as people share on social media how
ludicrous the Roseate we made the best
rosy like rosy season's upon us like
it's gonna be no accident you're not
putting an emphasis on on rosy an
accident yeah I'm not like four so we
haven't blended the white yet so I have
no idea
like you'll note I always say watch what
I do not what I say if I'm like really
quiet about the white in a month it's
gonna be like [ __ ] we couldn't figure
out the blend like the Rose even smelled
like when I think about the horseshit
that whispering angel is in comparison
to empathy I'm passionate and that by
the way I envy and respect the [ __ ] out
of whispering angel they build a monster
I just think we made a disproportionate
better wine it is what it is and if they
think I'm wrong I challenge them the
blind taste everybody on earth and see
who wins I think we're gonna win 5.7
billion to two billion well I can't wait
to try it I'm looking forward to it Nick
do didn't you order empathy Thank You
Corey I Love You Man see ya don't
disrespect the view you know who I don't
think bought it Andy Kay alright good
look how weird Babbage's acting Babbitt
gonna buy a basic Batman you're such a
dick
Babbitt if you don't order a 3-pack
tonight it's like fundamentally over
like I don't know Babbitt was acting so
weird yeah that wasn't me by the way I
I never I've never believed in
lie-detector more than right now that
was the most awkward I'm so pissed we
don't cameras watching babban right now
he was just so weird I was like talkies
like that was so hurt that bad when
you're buying a three pack subscription
I'm not forcing you more like I know
you're you know like I don't want to
overextend you like financially but you
have to you have to buy it you do that
you know your time's up all right
raagh off I know that I'm not the same
advice I have for small companies like
it's like this is real this is why big
companies lose this is why big companies
are slow this is big company advice not
small company advice if anything what
advice do I give there's a CEO that's
reading this reply really leans in and
actually understands that cancerous
employees massively hurt the bottom line
even if they're the biggest servitor Hey
well why my breeze in the comments hope
they didn't hear that comment put one of
the comments in that was attention to
driver just when it under imagine that
patricia cheers pink pink pin up what up
Patricia it's Gary
Patricia it's Gary Vaynerchuk Gary yes
yeah hello can you hear me I can I see
you
what rich are you here I am can you hear
me I can hear you perfectly perfect
sorry I heard some background noise I
thought it was from my end
no worries what's cooking hey I just
ordered because I believe in you
appreciate all that you've done all the
content you put out how often
like you are and love the label empathy
I appreciate that
are you one drinker I am a wine drinker
and I can't wait to try it I'm normally
a red but looking forward to the road
day when looking forward to sharing by
the way like one thing I'm already
massively confident about is how
ridiculous the red is mainly because we
know the sources of grapes we know the
winemaker we have like what Reds do you
tend to drink yeah normally at Cabernet
and I'm normally you know Sonoma or you
know Napa
I like yeah yeah you know oh my gosh um
oh my gosh no they're like I like the
road I like silver oak I like is it oh
my gosh recalling like yeah let me stick
on that if you're a silver world drink
yeah I'm telling you what yeah okay
I'm telling right now in October you're
gonna drink a bottle of empathy red and
as a silver oak drinker you know 40 50
$60 wine yeah you're gonna pay - you
paid you just paid 20 for empathy red
I'm telling you right now please do me
this favor please email me the first
time you have a bottle of it it's gonna
change your world like the thing I'm
singly most excited about is one forty
fifty sixty dollar red drinkers drink
the first bottle of empathy red that to
me is gonna be my crowning moment
because like genuine we keep saying it's
a forty dollar wine for 20 bucks I I do
think we're gonna make a red wine that's
gonna compete with $60 wines that's
awesome I will definitely let you know
thank you
anything I can answer for you I actually
did not have a question i I just wanted
to feel like hey that's a thank you
thank you so much from the body welcome
have a great great day you're welcome
thank you thank you you too what up
Instagram resume writer King Boris I'm
gonna put you in actually cuz you my guy
I'm cooking for us in real quick how
many more call oh good thank you name
sixteen got some work to do
should we only have an hour and [ __ ]
13 minutes we're gonna have to go speed
round LinkedIn we have to remember that
every culture is different as it's
driven by its leader and what it's like
to be there is very respectful of the
various cultures wrong and remain super
soft like by attaching our stops that
culture that reflects our own values
couldn't agree more
just gonna agree more good go in here
what up Belarus kimandrob owes one of my
favorite human beings on earth
congratulations on the audition of their
family cabs I hope you got a note on
that and I love you so [ __ ] much
Colin Kevin I love you the car there
Kevin up ah yeah hello
I know he's an investor about women
senator hello who's this Gary Gary
what's up man life is tremendous thank
you for supporting empathy with your
recurring case order of empathy dude I'm
not you will not believe this I'm like
laying in bed and I see you go live and
my wife is about to go to sleep and I'm
like and I'm like oh my gosh that's like
I guess I've already been meaning to buy
wine anyway and when I thought you'd go
alive and say that I was like oh my god
this is the opportunity that I've been
waiting for you I have been a huge fan
of yours not not much I'm saying years
like years and it started when a really
a partner business partner mining you
saw this little coffee coffee company
little subscription company and my
business partner sent me a send me a
video of yours and said dude you need to
watch this
this guy reminds me of you and when I
started watching herself I said oh my
yes it just clicks I'm like yes yes yes
yeah yeah no now my entire family is
asleep so like I'm walking around in my
garage trying to like this by this it's
like it's like crazy but uh but man I
mean really I just want to I just want
to thank you dude I mean I've been
following yourself for years and we've
had like a couple of like brief
exchanges of me like reaching over
crowds of people to have you sign my
book
down in Tampa during a startup it was
[ __ ] crazy
dude it was crazy right dude I literally
felt like Andrew Dice Clay in 1987 in
that theater that d-roc were you with me
iris you're right dude that helped like
honestly I feel like that was one of the
most that the energy in that theater
that night was [ __ ] out of control it
was the same man like I that was like
the I've never seen I mean and props to
you because I've just never seen an
entrepreneur be like Rockstar status
cuz that degree like I mean it was just
the crowd was just insane
honestly like I'm living a like a wild
life and like have like my level of
micro internet fame that night in that
theater like I felt like [ __ ] you know
like literally like a comedian at the
height of their career that's why I used
and act like it was it was Eddie Murphy
raw it was [ __ ] like Chris Rock when
he wore that black suit it was like
Kevin Hart right like it was like the
energy in that room was like it was
different it was like a it was like a
stand-up comedy celebrity vibe more than
like a business keynote don't you agree
yeah I was very much like oh my god
Gary's about to be like mop like
literally I think like everybody was
resting the stage into the mic when I
thought when they said okay like
everybody line up for questions I
thought some oh my gosh like the line I
thought the mics but yeah I thought
people are gonna get like seriously
injured running for the microphone I
agree man listen well keep going
anything I can answer for you I'm just
glad we conducted like this yeah man me
too it I just I just really really
appreciate everything you've done and
it's cool I'm definitely gonna drink it
I got to tell you last year
see I've never really been a wine
drinker and last year so
give you a little bit of background on
myself Iona I would have bets the
dealerships down in Gainesville Florida
so like we've we've made like motor
scooters the way to get around college
campuses yeah and and so I have the best
dealer best I actually flew us out to
Italy last year and and I went to go
like where the factory and and you know
I'm like we're going out to dinner down
in Italy and I'm like oh man like I
don't know like you're like I'll just
drink wine I drink my own I don't really
like wine I always gives me a headache
well why that's because they're like
well that's because you drink [ __ ] wine
and and so we ended up drinking wine at
at these dinners and yeah I just fell in
love man I was like this is so good and
like once you get the wine bug for real
like it's really funny to watch people
like flip from like super not interested
to like you have that one bottle of wine
you're like yo whoa what the [ __ ] like
it's really one of my favorites
obviously I grew up in the industry so I
watched a lot of 20 year old true my
friends my contemporaries my homies like
make that flip what's really interesting
is I'm a big fan of sour beer and I
think a beer is actually an incredible
gateway to wine as a palate play so like
watching sour beer explode has been
really exciting to me because I'm like I
see a lot of reactions you know it
sounds like babban just finally bought
bad let's clap it up for babban finally
[Applause]
bad and literally the creative direct
like like we pulled gap we pulled babban
out of the gutters of [ __ ] Florida
the guy can't buy [ __ ] nine bottles
of wine for our family but thank God he
finally did [ __ ] gay man for the
hoodie is no problem but like [ __ ]
supporting the family no chance no
deport family babban over here well hey
man look I do I have I do have a
question I want to ask you that I don't
know if you've ever been asked before
it's like it's a little bit more on the
technical side though because we because
I do a lot I do a vlog you know I
started doing vlogging really
documenting my journeys out here and
it's doing really well I saw the podcast
- and the thing is like I see sometimes
where you guys will like wear out
people's faces or you know like are you
getting are you getting people to
releases pardon your vlogs nope okay so
when people like when you like bleep out
you know numbers or something in like
one of your forties and that kind of
stuff like is that because they
requested it or because I wanted a blue
moon once a blue moon will post game but
like 90% is our subjective call
d-roc has a good flavor you know babban
was great learning dustin a new crew
like caleb like they're starting to
learn the rocks kind of watching a
little bit like we're learning I mean
look we had a week about a month ago I'm
looking at Andy and Dustin we had a week
about a month ago we're like three
different pieces of content caused us
some headaches because we didn't like
blurt everything or the context was lost
or the way we titled it so it comes with
the territory but the answer is no but
do you have to go back and take that
down or like what are you doing that you
take it down for a second blow out well
whatever or beep out or at it out and
repost it right okay yep all right cool
that's it well I gotta tell you man like
I have all my long list go if I
accomplish all my goals this year like
my reward to myself is to come up there
and do a 4d dude very serious note now
it's in the Sasha group not vaynermedia
this for DS I mean dude dude it's
[ __ ] crazy right like so the price is
going up right - 12 K so 12 K from 10k
oh yeah by the way empathy whines comm
slash barter or it's like just Google
empathy wines barter by the way crowd is
trying to steal some cases here this is
an inside joke not an inside joke this
inside secret most people don't know you
can actually barter on empathy wines if
you buy twelve thousand dollars worth of
wine you get an empathy you get a 4dc so
like literally you can get twelve
thousand dollars worth of [ __ ] wine
for free you're getting the benefit for
no [ __ ] reason like you're hurting
like Mainers revenue it was my idea dude
anyway I can't wait to see you I'm gonna
be in Tampa soon we just signed I don't
know if you're following Boehner sports
serendipitously you like sports but we
just signed Tampa Bay is running back
Peyton Barbour
so I promised his mom that I'd come down
to
a bucks game so I'll be in Tampa yeah my
buddies near dude Kwami Gator in
Gainesville and then do and the beg your
buddies dude pain barbers with Vayner
sports egg go ahead yeah so anyway
thanks bro talk to you soon hey man real
real quick one last thing while I think
Bob memory go ahead all right all right
hey so I have a podcast on here called
the WH o AG and B podcast I'm not gonna
ask you to be on or anything like that
because I definitely but uh is there any
way you're being smart here's what I let
me give you a recommendation you can go
to empathy wines barter page submit a
certain amount of wine bought to get me
to be a guest and no joke when I'm
desperate to sell twenty five thousand
cases this is how I get tricked all
right like I did I don't have the money
for the Hat I got it but like I just
want like a selfie video or if you buy
if you're going Craigslist and buy laser
discs you can buy for exchange five
dollars of water for $6,000 worth of
laser discs because I don't know if I've
been watching for a while yeah yeah
don't do the flip like real I don't
understand all the I I don't understand
how people don't know that the flip life
like if you have ten dollars to your
name the fastest way to get to 10,000 is
the flip life yeah do you want to I've
been
yes yes this looks crazy man no watching
all those good videos thanks dries down
yeah we according the one let me watch
trash talk
yes I've walked all over man doing like
my favorite dude big [ __ ] real quick I
apologize well I'm memory who has one of
the great Instagram accounts where he
goes crazy voice over in sports clips I
don't know if you follow him dude you
have to follow Bob memory he's the boy
scout now of the Buffalo Wild Wings
commercial during March Madness
he just posted in the comments Nora he
wants 15 cases yeah you pay attention
dude I'm like I'm walking around my
garage like I told you while you're
saying this trying to figure out what I
can sell right now is [ __ ] sitting
there in store [ __ ] if you [ __ ]
hustle and like like just list it dude
dude everybody who's only [ __ ] 10,000
people that are watch
right now literally 80% of them because
I don't make assumptions 80% of them
have a thousand dollars worth of stuff
in their home right now 80% have a
thousand dollars with the stuff on eBay
and Craigslist and Facebook marketplace
and mark ARRA that they don't use ever
again easy there's at least breathe out
at least 3,000 in here from stuff my
kids don't even use [ __ ] garage now
what you know Raj sale and sell it for
hundred three thousand do you watch a
trash talk where I bought the [ __ ]
Olympic pins for 20 bucks and sold
different like Boeing 2500 bucks
there's only at ridiculous of course who
needs 5,000 bucks cuz you need twenty
dollars in America to get the five on
the fly
yeah yeah I mean that's already ready
[ __ ] him Ivan said the collective I send
the [ __ ] dictator CEO she or he has
to decide I don't [ __ ] care about the
[ __ ] entitled underneath a [ __ ] a
winner that's awesome I'm talking about
stop being a [ __ ] dick and looking
the other way for somebody that's
earning you money at the expense of the
culture of your company cuz you're
looking at micro short term finances
instead of long term macro finances dick
you got that
but keep saying what he was gonna say
dear sir
sir you clearly made assumptions from
what I said I was saying the CEO has to
under like he's making the assumption
that I'm listening to the masses I don't
listen the masses for [ __ ] I'm making
the decision and watching got it
he he he thinks I'm talking about
democracy I'm talking about dictatorship
you want some want some wine you drink
wine have you tried it yet
you love your to new for me this is a
[ __ ] cabin took six years to utter
it right Nick knows Nick was just
laughing they could barely hear that and
he's still laughing he knows you're a
dick face famine but I'm pumped right
now now I love you who's this
11 Mary Ann this is Gary Vaynerchuk
I'm Gary I love you I love you back wash
I love May I'm looking at May right now
May is on my team she's a [ __ ]
gangster and everybody's now shaking
their heads which even triple confirms
it but Mary Ann let's focus on you where
are you from and what are you gonna do
with the wine so I currently live in
Atlanta Georgia but I am from White
Sulphur Springs West Virginia home of
the Greenbrier and I am a serial
entrepreneur I flip products online as a
hobby
I own a landscape company I to go and I
listen I've been listening to you for
like about four years now and literally
I'm just when I saw that I could speak
to you I was like I got excited by this
why I love
but I buy $3 wine at all these so there
you go well listen so now I'm super
flattered what are you gonna do with
real like this is real wine you've been
buying $3 [ __ ] wine now you're about
to get three cases of real wine do you
have a plan for it well I'm gonna drink
it not probably share it holding I'm
actually gonna say something super weird
and I'm not kidding this is gonna be a
learning experience for a lot of people
are you enjoying the 3/4 dollar wine
that you're buying I love it I drank
them earlier tonight so you're gonna
this is gonna curveball people I love
that and I've had three $4 wine I've
liked as well I just want to give you a
huge warning this is to what you just
paid $20 for wine that is actually forty
to fifty dollar quality because of the
deals I was able to get who cuz who I've
been in the wine world Plus secretly
Babin d-roc all of us are working on
this huge documentary for it and we're
gonna really make the vineyards that we
work with famous so they're gonna be
able to charge more for their grapes
it's a whole thing you're about to drink
these wines and after you drink these
wines those three and four dollar wines
that you like now are gonna taste like
dog [ __ ] thank you
so I'm not no I really I mean like
there's a weird thing thank you I'm
being sued and I I appreciate you saying
thank you because you've been following
me and you know this I'm serious when I
say this you may want to consider to not
drink the wines I am gonna drink the
wine and probably because I'm making so
much money
I was probably buy every single year
from you for the rest of my life
well now I'm freaking out of happiness
let's go she could drop the mic you're
amazing cherry can I kiss you
listen listen Gary I'm gonna tell you
this really quick cuz I know you have to
call all the people right so I have a
great TV show I di like April 2017 was
like the worst time of my life and I
literally was at rock bottom and I
literally stepped into this landscaping
business by accident and and I don't
know really anything about this industry
and every day when I'm living my life
I'm a single mom of two boys I have a
five year old a three year old and
everyday I'm an entrepreneur and I'm
going out and I'm
I'm doing sales and so forth and I'm
always thinking like God put in my
spirit like I was gonna have this TV
show so I got this idea that I think it
would be amazing to follow like three to
four entrepreneurs on a reality show
that's living a life like mine I okay
how do I help I think we should just
have a conversation like I can email
them by email of your idea and I'm gonna
put you in touch with William Morris
Endeavor the biggest talent agency in
Hollywood I've got huge connections they
rep me and I'm gonna [ __ ] change your
life if it's good idea it's it's I mean
I think if the TV crew I know other
entrepreneurs and I don't want to say
like you either I don't want ya send me
the full idea and I'm gonna forward it
as powerful [ __ ] TV agents in the
world okay okay dun dun I love you done
magic I love you Gary I love you let me
have you a super secret and almost
nobody knows those are really hoping
this windows and this is clearly the
rose a talking there's a very good
chance that vaynermedia is gonna off
open an office in Atlanta so we'll be
talking yes I love it I [ __ ] love it
women all right love you see ya I think
your landscaping I can do the manscaping
I like with my lower thing I like
Japanese apple trees okay I don't know
what they are but that's real either
what Google I love you SIA thank you
alright let's keep this going the
Rosie's kicking in shit's getting weird
let's [ __ ] questions let's go like
this might be the time to tag friends
cuz things are about to get weird Nick
do do not leave I know you have a side
hustle but don't leave do not leave it's
ten thirty seven if you drop the zero
that means one thirty seven pm baby
let's go raagh up what can I answer for
you guys if you want me to answer your
questions our dare Japanese apple trees
I don't think
let's go let's go call rocket Andy what
are you doing I see a coat dude we're
[ __ ] just starting to have fun you're
going what irony emotionally intelligent
people is important but companies need
to also prop adapt their processes to
scale diverse and inclusive behavior
sure if you're looking for great
innovators you should look beyond happy
faces people are so lost man people just
didn't understand what I was saying in
that video I agree let me say it one
more time for the people in the back
I'm telling in this video I'm speaking
about firing people who are cancerous
individuals who happen to also drive
disproportion of financial success and
I'm speaking to leaders and owners of
the behavior of looking the other way
because of short-term financial value in
lieu of long-term financial value look
the Japanese we may make us exclusive
version of empathy one of Japanese
apples Japanese macaque and Eve are you
leaving we're just starting Condon on
DPA was Andy here on Samba o us actually
[ __ ] but he was coming from courtside
Knicks [ __ ] fancy boy he's like
LeBrons best friend now gage three clubs
hello Tim Tim it's Gary Vaynerchuk hey
how are you doing I'm doing extremely
well
Nate's got a weird face cuz he thought
your name was gage
oh my son's name is gage understood well
listen first of all thank you so much
for the substantial otter it means a lot
to me
how are you welcome what are you gonna
do with that oh I'm not sure I'm not
sure what do you learned taken care I'm
in Lancaster Pennsylvania I love it I
know it well what can I answer for you
my
so my son's a huge fan of yours and he's
got me interested in you as well watched
a lot of your stuff most of the stuffs
been through him and what suggest the
social media is an area that I'm not an
expert at okay um I own a small
restaurant okay about 40 C restaurant
kind of a quick service sort of place
barbecue and burritos okay love it so
we're about a year we'll be two years in
Jean traffic has been absolutely
horrible okay so I'm a I'm a big I've
been in business for many many years but
it's always been paper color print type
stuff okay so trying to give the social
media thing well no let me give you a
hot take immediately I want you to
Google one my literally verbatim one
mile radius
Facebook Ads one mile radius
Instagram ads if you run ads in a
one-mile radius of York us ours and you
realize that you need to make lots of
different content until you find
something that works it will change your
traffic at your business okay I couldn't
be especially like be BQ and burrito
like like if you're trying to hit that
15 to 40 year old set Instagram Facebook
will crush for you you can only run ads
in a one-mile radius and you can try 53
different creative ideas you'll find
something that works you yourself need
to become the best practitioner in it it
will really change your business brother
it will change your business the way
that Direct Mail changed businesses in
the 50s 60s and 70s
it will change your business the way
email and Google AdWords changed
businesses in the 90s and 2000's okay
yeah I mean it look of a total believer
in it I think it's it is the wave of now
and the future and it's free I mean
basically free well it's really cool
about this real quick it's free if you
think it's about organic it's not free
if you think about running ads but it's
a great deal
if you think about running ads well I
mean to me what robots very good hold on
one second apologize I literally saw my
Twitter scream Duane you want your phone
is that your phone yeah you're stuck bro
you shouldn't have [ __ ] made your
phone available you knew I was on to
11:30 yeah it's a huge mistake one of
the worst mistakes you want to leave
right whose phone is it but why do you
need it no we're good
don't worry about stories see you doing
you need to become the practitioner of
those ads it will really really matter
and like and to your point it's it's a
it's of the now and whether it's of the
future or not is irrelevant it's of the
now and that matters the most
so so here's my basic question is you
know as far as running and everything or
the actual ads themselves I'm great with
that I mean I've been in marketing for
many many years okay I know that's in
the past
but will this tell me this one mile
radius thing will just tell me the more
about content of the ads that I should
be using I know like like the difference
between Instagram ads and Facebook ads
the appearance the content the offers of
whatever you know that's the meat of
what I'm looking for why being or media
is a huge company because the sign the
strategy and the art and the ability to
make those things is what are the best
in the world of so you need to that's
what you need to figure out let me give
you something that's very important and
a quick read on if it's working off yes
offers I would immediately run into one
mile radius come into our counter use
the secret word XYZ and get free extra
guacamole or [ __ ] of skewer but you
know what I mean that's the quickest way
for you to figure out if people are
actually [ __ ] even seeing it make it
with you in it and say I'm the owner of
this
we're what I'm running like literally no
joke I'm very into literal hey guys
what's your name again I apologize I'm
very [ __ ] Jose yeah no worries
what's your name him Tim yeah Tim if you
were in an ad I'm gonna do an ad for you
right now into the camera of what I
would do
hey guys I'm Tim I'm the owner of the
bvq burrito place I've run this Facebook
or Instagram ad literally within a
one-mile radius first of all if you stop
by one of my stores and you see me
please say hello I've loved being part
of the Lancaster Pennsylvania community
also
Shh don't tell anybody this is just for
Facebook and Instagram if you come to
the counter and you say the secret word
Gary Vee we will give you a free 16
ounce soda we will give you a free
burrito we will give you a second taco
we will give you a steak we will give
you I would run that ad immediately okay
got it
I like it I'm all about that I'll tell
you why I don't love doing induce kind
of free [ __ ] cuz you get the worst kind
of customers why I like it is that first
week or two you'll figure out how many
people are actually seeing it cuz
they'll come out they'll come out and
then after two weeks you're like [ __ ] a
lot of people are seeing this you change
the creative to not make it about
inducing them you make it about brand or
something about your business do you
understand right yeah cadence it's like
it's like a great boxer it's like it's
like Jab Jab right hook right like too
many people think in one term I think in
multiple terms I'm a chess player in a
world of checker players so what I just
told you was a chess move I'm gonna run
that for 14 days get a feel if my
[ __ ] traffic explodes I'm like [ __ ]
this is working now let me change it
because I don't want just the bottom
dwellers who are just looking for you
we've got it yeah yeah what about rata G
that was an insight see when I drink a
little Rose a and get a little tipsy I
start showing a little bit more of my
smarts you know I'm kind of the same way
mine's more wrong but
cool so that's the creative got it I got
it yeah I like that a lot okay I love
you with all my heart
trash is in the [ __ ] thread the best
[ __ ] like literally one of the best
humans I've ever met Josh McCown Jets
quarterback who's like really you put
out a statement debating if he's coming
back family like just a quality man Tim
I really appreciate your order man it
means a lot to me you got it I gotta run
line see ya bye yep let's get an extra
braga what do you got what do we think
about babban ordering tonight when
didn't you ordered Iraq make sense you
two [ __ ] dopes all right Rob no cuz
Voice devices aren't with you at all
times now they can be I think the phone
becomes the voice device I think Siri
this is war series this is where Apple
[ __ ] up they had [ __ ] Siri five
years ago devastated for them somebody
just wrote babiness toxic
hey let's go buy building apps because
apps built on top of Lex are gonna be
big deals and so and I think apps games
any games on voice are gonna be huge
think about Dungeons and Dragons it's
like us talking think about an Alexa
like I think gaming on voice devices in
seven years or monstrous Lisa hello Lisa
this is Gary Vaynerchuk and I just want
to thank you from the bottom my heart
for ordering Club empathy oh thank you
you're welcome
how are you I'm doing awesome
how are you really good thank you for
ordering yummy plans for the wine you
got any ideas actually I have a couple
of my own can you want to tell me
like some secret [ __ ] Wow there's always
secret [ __ ] right but I like that is
there anything I can answer for you
tonight uh that one we're definitely
drinking the wine good and can't wait
for the red to come out yeah and very
source note like just from like the
quality we are so like you know so
here's how we've been talking we kind of
know the room so just on a strategy just
so you know we think we've made the best
for like literally the single best Rosa
like I think on Instagram in May and
June you won't be able to like not not
see people giving love to empathy
because we're gonna do a lot of
influencer marketing I'm gonna sudden a
bunch of bottles to my influence or
friends and then I just think people are
gonna taste it and share it I think the
red we're making is a city on red call
it prisoner Plus how much red you drink
but like it's gonna be a monster the
biggest wild card in our family is the
white we're like which is really fun cuz
Thursday I'm literally gonna be in Napa
or Sonoma where's the nappin we're gonna
be blending and I don't not like and
it's not that I have like concern I
think we're trying to create something
that doesn't exist on the white some
super excited about it so go ahead okay
so if you can create something in the
white that would make me drink a white
that would be amazing so on some real
[ __ ] have you ever had a white that
you'd liked now now I already love your
vibes so I think you're gonna shoot it
straight
ready do you believe this is huge do you
believe that you think that way because
in the culture of society people think
red is better than white now I think the
exact opposite I think the majority of
people drink white because they don't
have enough knowledge about red well but
that's but that's kind of like the point
right like like to me the thing that I
tried to do with Wine Library TV in 2006
to 2011 was to get people into a place
of treating wine the way they treat food
which is nobody apologizes or overthinks
why they like a cheeseburger verse
fake versus oysters but there's this
whole culture around wine that
intimidates people and I just want
people to like what they like but try
other [ __ ] yeah I think and people feel
safe they feel safe with white and red
seems like out of their comfort zone so
they don't try it
where do you sit them and I think me I
think yeah so I think the Rose day world
has taken off Ryan Preece because it's
middle ground I got it
where do you live Naples Florida Hobbit
that is a mean are you coming here by
the way yeah I come to Naples all the
time um you do yeah I do I like like
okay well you have my number now so
let's get let's hook it up anything what
can I answer for you all right so here's
um I have a two-part question
listen I I watch you I watch your
podcast I'm on your videos I'm in your
emails rep I love what you do love your
message straightforward no [ __ ] and
I have a brick and mortar yep I have a
health and wellness business yes is very
successful yep I have something that
nobody else is doing across the country
understood I can possibly scale that
okay however my biggest problem in that
brick and mortar business is employees
and staff that's a Superman creating the
culture and I know it comes from me it
does but I have to get out I have to be
25% of the business and 75% running the
business and I haven't been able to make
that yeah you have to hire regional or
store managers and you have to fire them
when they're not executing within the
first 200 days 200 days is the mark 200
days is your mark that arbitrary but it
feels good to me I like six months you
can get an obnoxious read on somebody in
six months yeah I think what happens
though and I might be I'm speaking for
myself but I think I might also be
speaking for a small business
brick-and-mortar is that you just need a
body in the transition and so if they're
breathing if they're breathing you hire
them listen I've lived in retail for the
first 12 years 13 years of my career
that is short-term thinking I get it
well great you'll get short-term results
I get thank you so how do you get past
that how do you get past that short-term
I always tell people this analogy if
somebody called me and said hey I want
to get into shape I say you have to eat
better and you have to exercise the the
advice is simple the execution is hard
right you know what you have to do is
find the right leaders in your store the
advice is simple the execution is hard
what makes the execution easier is
constantly interviewing for somebody
better than a person you have currently
which gives you the leverage to fire the
person you currently have the biggest
mistake that people do is they don't
execute on the offense once they have
something in place once you have the
current manager in place you should be
in concurrent interviewing her or his
replacement in case they don't work out
and that is the biggest mistake that
people make nobody does that
I did and that's why I won okay I'm
right that's like a little bit of a
different kind of really yeah totally
makes sense so let me ask you here's
part two of my question
I am a cancer survivor I am just
recently a best-selling author of a book
called shine beyond cancer and I am
launching that second part of a business
because I'm always creating yep and I'm
an entrepreneur and so I feel like I
don't know something crazy
yeah the first business we just talked
about on the retail side do you want a
hundred percent of it 100% one of the
things that I would tell you that you
should sleep on is should you give up
20% of the business being earned out
over 40 years for a minority partner
that allows you to be the Contra preneur
that you are that's [ __ ] crazy
because I have been thinking about that
cuz you're [ __ ] smart now before you
give somebody 20% earned out over four
years which means how I would structure
it is if they don't make it to your one
they get nothing if they make it to your
one they get 5% of the business are you
following me okay so now all of a sudden
you're less scared right because when
people hear that for me they're like I'm
[ __ ] scared what if I pick the wrong
person good news you have 11 months and
three [ __ ] and five six six seventh
weeks to figure out if it's the right
person before you give them five points
got it hey yeah what I love is you
rotating managers until you find
somebody you love because that's the
right person to make that bet with not
somebody from the outside that you think
is right exactly but it also has a
business that can be franchised and
grown and scale cool so now you need to
decide what makes you happier being a
creative entrepreneur or maximizing the
business that you have or be like me
where 80% of your time and a hundred
percent of your energy
is to be building your core thing aka
Boehner and 20% of your time and the
extra twenty to fifty percent of your
energy builds other [ __ ] so you can be
creative that is the secret of me okay
that 88 of me of my time but 100% of my
energy is CEO of vaynermedia which is
why it's a monster business 20% of my
time and the extra 50% of my energy is
around Gary Vee and all the my other
mishegoss including [ __ ] empathy
wines right but okay so what I hear you
saying is that what I have and what I
can scale and what I can turn into
Millions
yep and is what is literally what I have
in my brick and mortar I just have to
learn how to scale that correct here I'm
not the person correct
you're not the scaler you're the creator
I'm the creator now you have to find
somebody who's not a creator who wants a
quote unquote take advantage and get 20%
of the business for being the scaler and
both of you win you ever see like a 70
year old dude like married to like a 34
year old woman
dude I live in Naples Florida all the
time so what's happening in that
situation is both parties have made a
trade that values both parties right
right everybody everybody's winning
everybody's getting what they need
correct
that's what I want you to do as an
entrepreneur you can find somebody who's
an incredible scale or an executor an
operator who's just a manager of a great
company but they just have a good salary
now she or he has the ability to own 20%
of a business but for you it allows you
to do other [ __ ] because you're creative
as [ __ ] understand understand so now I
have this okay so I'm sort of this show
by real [ __ ] I'm sorry and I have this
book and I have
experience and I have this coaching and
I have this online opportunity and again
it's all about creating and it's about
creating content and it's about creating
value and it's about giving people what
they need and so now I'm torn between do
I put my energy into the brick and
mortar and think that and scale that or
do I put my energy charge right ready
we're gonna end with that I think you
need to hire extra men this manager for
your brick and mortar who has the
potential to be your minority partner or
find somebody who scaled brick and
mortar as an executive like who is the
number seven at orange theory four years
ago right you see where I'm going
yep that's it okay I love you all right
love you and hey when you get to Naples
I'm gonna send you I'm gonna send you an
email when you come from Naples we're
hanging out you're gonna sign my bottles
of wine I'm giving them away love it
done in see you bye bye goodnight I want
to talk to everybody
anybody who [ __ ] bought it I need to
[ __ ] talk to I just drank a whole
[ __ ] bottle ah I cannot believe I
drink a whole bottle nah dude it's it's
a uncomfortably easy to drink everybody
whines I'm comfortably easy to [ __ ]
drink now and have any wine is that come
on guys order three pack would you [ __ ]
right babban like everybody right now
just go to ebony wines calm and order
three pack subscriptions nine [ __ ]
bottles wine you drink nine [ __ ]
bottles of wine and if not you're
drinking like nine bottles of [ __ ]
vodka just replace it next one up
Instagram and sometimes [ __ ] going
crunk what up King Boris bro I'm under
21 and you can't [ __ ] buy it dude
[ __ ] raagh off what do you got on like
then
this one's awesome boys I believe I
believe that voice will be a tollbooth
to our society no different than search
was thus b2b will play out if people are
searching for you on Google they'll be
searching for you how do you show up as
the result will be discussion good
please Twitter the 244 of you please
please please please my empathy whines
not calm month of cancel Twitter so I
can restart and have 800 of you hello
hello it's Gary Vaynerchuk hey Gary
how's it going good man what's your name
this is Luke from Minnesota Luke I
appreciate brother are you a Vikings fan
we're all Vikings fans here in Minnesota
that's a solid point dude what anthony
barb did to the [ __ ] Jets by remaking
on the contract broke my [ __ ] heart I
believe it but you guys got bail now so
it should be a good year right yeah but
we should have [ __ ] both dudes but
you should have both yeah anyone
surprised but I guess he's loyal back to
us right yeah but he shouldn't have
[ __ ] said to us that he was [ __ ]
gonna side with us that's true I'm
pissed anyone have to get off you all it
dude thank you so much for buying
empathy what do you do with the wine I'm
gonna give it away and then uh
throw a little party here this summer
down at the beach house and have some
friends over love you thank you so much
bro what can I help you have the plan
thank ya so recently I just made a job
change six six years I'm 36 years old
had a really good run the last three
years our average here in our county is
about 140,000 so it's very low probably
compared to obviously where you're at or
even in Minneapolis still found amazing
well congratulations so it's a blown up
look 5.6 million I've been doing it sale
which equates you know it's about
150,000 in commissions recently I made a
job change well
I'm gonna continue the real estate
industry just because I'm passionate
about it I'm wondering on how to
position myself in a small market where
the talk is it's a wildfire here when
you make a job to inaudible we got about
ten ten thousand people so with that
being said we got a lot of realtor's
talking about Luke making the move
what's who's going to be doing is he
going to continue real estate the answer
is yes I'm going to be continuing real
estate however trying to get that
transition of part-time but explaining
to my clong that my hustle is still
there I mean I think you just [ __ ]
communicate it with LinkedIn and
Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
content just keep communicating that
rate pick the jabs take the jabs right
it's just communication like people
grossly underestimate communication so
service decline to the best of ability
get back to them just keep servicing
servicing in that's right because you're
really you're building up karma it's
like tonight right like like right I'm
giving so much in the macro and it's
stunning how few people that are
watching the stream are actually buying
empathy when I'm desperately asking this
is like I'm in plead mode I'm like
telling people like I've sold 5000 cases
I need to sell 25,000 like this is no
joke but it's okay because you just keep
servicing and karma takes over in the
macro long turn so what to say when
you're when you're in a listing
presentation and the sellers that are
looking to hire you to list their
property thing repaired you just went
part-time what do you say that my part
times better than the [ __ ] [ __ ]
other people's full-time got it
just be confident well if you can
actually back it up because otherwise
you're full of [ __ ] right right when I
talk to people they're like Gary your
keynote speech is two hundred thousand I
can get somebody else for forty thousand
I'm like I'm a better deal at two
hundred thousand and that other person
at forty thousand and no joke bro I
genuinely believe it awesome you know
like like
it's not super complicated like like
back to like keeping this meta like I
know that we're making 40 to 50 to $60
wine for 20 bucks
like we're pushing hard right now but
when I tell you that net the next 30 to
60 days on Facebook and Instagram when
people try the rose' and post about it
will be when we grow so when I come out
here and say look 40 all of mine for 20
bucks like you have to deliver on that
bro right I genuinely believe even
listening to you for [ __ ] two minutes
that your part time is better than 90%
of people's full time I believe that cue
I mean I don't know it's tell you Tom
Deion Sanders 1991 Braves that's true
hold on like [ __ ] apart talking homerun
for the Falcons was still better than
[ __ ] their alternatives which is why
they dealt with that fashek [ __ ] [ __ ]
of him being part time exactly does that
make sense what you know I fully
understand you I I appreciate your time
I appreciate everything you do and
giving out all the free content just
kind of like whatever I'll one else has
been saying tonight I appreciate it bro
tonight it's been super fun yeah I can't
believe you put down that bottle drink a
bottle of wine dude but he looks like a
chimpanzee like it's getting weird like
yes so I'm talking to this guy he
recorded it all so I can save it yeah of
course
it's done they are yeah we're saving
we're gonna post the whole [ __ ] thing
you'll be able to clip it
that's cool Harry see I appreciate it
thank you brother hello hello who's this
the drying there's a Gary [ __ ]
Vaynerchuk what's up man there's no
Hannah cutie I know hammy
I literally think you're a top 100
Instagram account in the world and
people are sleeping on your talent thank
you Gary
I tried by my bed do you think people
sleep on your talent because your sex
oriented even Trouty Trouty hits me
other like
I genuinely think when you post whatever
hammy [ __ ] empathy wine video you're
gonna post is which you're not charging
me for which you probably could charge
fifty thousand for it's gonna sell so
much [ __ ] wine I need to call you but
I'll tell you now in that post I kind of
need you to say hey like you I need to
break the fourth wall and after you're
done with your skip I need you to be
like hey Gary means a lot to me he's
helped me a lot like if you order it
would mean a lot to me that's when I
think I would sell a fuckload but like
trow DDMS means like yo he's like are we
cool with the handy thing he's got a ton
of dildo content on his account right
literally do him you'll love this Trouty
who's the best and he gets it like he's
not a [ __ ] prude he's just like
worried about he's like a businessman he
literally writes me he's like are we
like not in a great way he's like hey
just triple-checking
are we cool with sending hammy wine for
his skin I don't know if he know that
cuz they know that I barely consume
anything and don't give a [ __ ] he's like
just so yea good an obnoxious amount of
hammy TVs content is [ __ ] dildo [ __ ]
my reply was like nah he's like are we
cool with it my reply it was amazing on
this thread my reply was yep dude him my
bro after you make your little skit if
you figure out how to put like the last
five seconds breaking the wall being
like hey Gary's a homie this whole
channel has like he's a homie like
please please order I actually think it
might be the big like I feel like your
community is so gives a [ __ ] about you I
think we're gonna sell a [ __ ] load of
wine and I hope your whole premise is
like yo serve [ __ ] empathy wine
because you're gonna get [ __ ] lucky
tonight if you do no no I mean there's
gonna be no deal I'm so [ __ ] cocked on
this [ __ ] up in the bottle that much
I'm ready I'm ready I've been waiting
for any bottle that comes yeah I started
the cake it went out today right hammies
class yeah you'll be getting a shortly
bro I'm dying to hear what you're gonna
do like I'm like I'm all
out at bro do it her - [ __ ] you want you
know you're no dildos won't be dildo -
homonyms
dude whatever sells the both you know
your audience I know what I'm doing I
mean I did Groot three hundred and
twenty thousand people do we
I know it's sexually oriented but yeah I
trust you blindly I believe this bro
it's crazy that you and you know it's
really funny you know what's funny hammy
I [ __ ] hate the Patriots more than I
hate I don't know everything that's bad
in the world like I Hitler right like I
hate the people but I know you Bob
memory like it's amazing how much I love
the people from [ __ ] Boston area I
well while the human beings from the
Boston area until they talk about
football then I want to stab a pencil
through their [ __ ] dick hole there's
everything why it sounds like it's
getting twisted I can't wait to get
excited
Gary sounds right yeah I went to college
and Newton Mass I spend a ton of time
cuz now I tend like the hoods of
Massachusetts like AJ went to bu you
married an incredible girl from Boston
crowd ease from the Boston area I love
Boston humans especially pre-2001
when you guys still had ruggedness
you've won too many titles now you're a
bunch of [ __ ] soft dick faces Sports
Khairy but it's humans I [ __ ] love the
[ __ ] out of you hey Gary wait so why
would ya I do get a real I think I get
two real questions the first is I'm
interested in how you got to be able to
deliver it to Massachusetts because
that's that had it been difficult right
the life funny with liquid the most
exciting thing about empathy wines is
Wine Library and other retailers can't
ship to illinois's Texas in
Massachusetts but when you're a winery
you can ship to these states as a winery
that's why nice perfect yes yeah so it's
not easy that's nice I was always
wondering I was like
how to pull it off you know there's that
funny viral video when the kid asked me
about cannabis like I just posted on
Instagram one of my all-time great clips
is some kid from Houston complaining
he's lazy as [ __ ] like I roast him it's
a super viral clip we just posted on IG
TV but in there he says he's from
Houston I talked about hating Texas
because I can't ship there now with
empathy I finally can so I'm super fired
up okay perfect well I'm not gonna wait
this time we cut with it I don't
remember on a search know everybody's
watching hammy TV go follow the account
I mean look it's a little racy it's hit
minute are you you guys be on are you
guys married help me not yeah we're
getting that be on some boat can't see
when you guys came here the first thing
that went through my head is like dude
this guy's batting way over his head
she's way too cute on you bro I love it
like she's like a solid nine and you're
like a six like you know no I didn't get
it I'm Irish cutie you know what that
means right yeah but dude oh you're
[ __ ] charismatic as [ __ ] so it all
made sense to me
uh yeah everything I learned I'm from
Utah oh wow hey me anything so that the
greatest piece of content ever I like
I'm so fired up to see what you come up
with you can't imagine
yeah I get about seven gets written down
so that's what I do that I just think
all day throughout the day and I just
write up everybody right arching if
you're okay with sexually oriented
content cuz that's what it is
but it is with this fiance it's super
funny hammy TV one of the great accounts
on Instagram
what's the matter better anyway Gary
I'll let you get to your people all
right you need anything no thank you the
battery on the teeth on the Kim camera
all right uh YouTube and Facebook see ya
hopefully you're on Instagram and uh and
Twitter now let's go basically anything
you ever tell me in secret always is
potentially Oh Zach what's going on Gary
first of all thank you for the barters
thank you so much for the order tonight
you're welcome you're welcome yeah man
I've been following you for a long time
and definitely motivate me to get after
it and really excited too yeah by a
hundred plus cases of your wine with
some of my partners one of my clients a
cannabis company we're gonna meet you in
LA next month and yeah have a good time
and learn everything we can from you and
your team dude I [ __ ] love you bro I
can't wait to bring value what can i
what can I answer for you tonight uh
yeah I guess I guess I got worries for
you buzz gary is a rare feat like this
is like I don't know 15 times a month
I'm actually not that buzzed but there's
definitely something going on so I'm
definitely not normal so anything's
possible right now so far away yeah yeah
I guess my I guess my question for you
is I left my ad agency I worked at for
several years I left it at he just went
e-4 started my own and launched it here
in Anchorage Alaska and I guess the
hardest thing is hot what's what's the
best way to scale that going from you
know we did
we're on scale to do Forex what we did
last year but the problem we're we're
running into is how can we convince the
companies agents that how can we get new
clients to break the mold from the way
they're doing things with the old
agencies here and adopt a newer form of
doing any creating content going digital
ready since I lived it you don't spend
any time on people you don't spend any
time I saw that text you don't spend any
time on convincing people that are not
convinced about yeah this is a very
important point
what up haplin there's a very very
important point
you spend zero time trying to convince
people that are not bought in let's move
on correct
are you following it's a yeah it's a
very important point the reason I was
able to build Vayner from 0 to 150
million in seven years is because I
didn't spend time trying to convince
people I just moved on to the next
person and I guess it's pretty cool it's
pretty clear when they're when they're
not buying force go ahead brother oh
it's pretty clear when they're not
buying into when it's time to move on
yeah dude sometimes I'm in a meeting 7
minutes in and I just mail in next 23
minutes to get the [ __ ] out of there
because I realize they believe in
[ __ ] television commercials and
billboards
it's exactly what we run into here man
it's a conservative market and they're
[ __ ] running that [ __ ] [ __ ] in
Alaska it's a conservative world I'm in
[ __ ] New York and the Conservatives
[ __ ] yeah okay that's a good point
got it it's a great info it's a
conservative world like people don't
like change it's why people lose it's
why Sears and Toys R Us go out of
business it's why Netflix is putting
[ __ ] ABC and NBC out of business it's
a conservative [ __ ] world because 99
percent of people are in defense and run
on fear not on offense right and
optimism
yeah yeah no I totally get it I mean
we're doing a tax on you know [ __ ]
digital ads for people and showing them
the numbers and that they don't want to
keep doing it and so I guess that's
exactly what you're saying move on move
on move on wide net find your [ __ ]
[ __ ] crew and move on
got it I appreciate it won't take more
your time he and April next month can't
wait brother love you raga and you go
next hey what up Twitter [ __ ] love
you guys
Instagram what up I am Tott dot Tish
what do you got Piper good I love being
disagree
cool you know if they [ __ ] 90,000
[ __ ] a year on debt to learn Southern
culture go work a [ __ ] chick-fil-a in
[ __ ] Birmingham [ __ ] ridiculous
this whole [ __ ] argument about college
being about more truth rose
college being more things than [ __ ]
just education you're paying for the
[ __ ] [ __ ] education guys like
[ __ ] Christ like like if you want to
learn about southern culture and not pay
sixty three thousand a [ __ ] year and
collect debt you can just go to [ __ ]
Little Rock Arkansas and hang the [ __ ]
out like if we're really at a place
where college is getting credit for its
location this dude [ __ ] justified
college paying forty to eighty thousand
a year maybe collecting debt on where
the [ __ ] college is located are we
really at that place do you need more
college scandal as rich [ __ ] buy
their kids way in because they're so
[ __ ] insecure they want their kid to
go to Harvard to look good at the
Country Club
are we really keeping up the institution
of college in 2019 [ __ ] you what else
what else is college more than books and
classes because there's a lot I'm gonna
start a business penny five thousand
dollars a year and I'll let you hang out
with other 18 to 22 year olds I'll build
a big [ __ ] business as a matter of
fact I'll even fly in gonna and little
baby to entertaining [ __ ] faces
give me 80 [ __ ] thousand people
paying me $5,000 not eighty thousand not
seventy thousand give me 5k and you'll
learn about Southern culture Rogoff what
else's [ __ ] justify his [ __ ] spend
on that his parents wasted their money
on or he's collecting debt in perpetuity
oh that's very nice
babban meet lifelong friends here not a
[ __ ] work did you go to college of
course not did you make lifelong friends
here
[ __ ] d-roc your archrival friend like
what else does he justify ask him to be
paid for college or if it's parents paid
for it it's [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
need to drink a bottle in half a [ __ ]
rose a to say this is [ __ ] I can
teach you
southern culture and [ __ ] make you
friends and you can pay me a hundred
sixty thousand over four years
don't let this [ __ ] collect that
sounds like somebody that has his
parents paying for college
show me where he's out of 28 years old
friends and frat get the [ __ ] out of
here super glad you [ __ ] can't the
[ __ ] in here get the [ __ ] out of here
where does the rise in rings I feel it
while your party is hello hello hi hi
it's Gary Vaynerchuk how are you what's
right what's your name darling my name
is Ray Nia Henderson I'm in Upper
Marlboro Maryland Ramaiya thank you so
much
first of all for ordering the club it
means the world to me oh my god I go to
college
what's that I was like I was just
missing or anionic oh my god Alondra me
Isola do you just change your shirt
you're six but you're get over here I
either six back online
dude you look great what the [ __ ] was
that
dude I'm proud of you that [ __ ] sick
hold on show me one more time you don't
need to show I need to see it do you
look great
have you been really focused this last
three months have you seen how focused
phil has been phil looks great
who's me bad Syd right no see looks fine
who's been bad but who comes to mind
when I say that okay good
all right man go ahead hi hi what's
going on um so I'm perfect or why
because I own a sewing school in
Maryland okay I'm and I told um
different zones and so I've been buying
my like service and my clients customers
or whatever and I thought oh great
I serve my customers it would be why I
love you so much for that I really
appreciate it what what in my content
has brought you the most value so I've
been struggling with like how to focus
and so I've heard you say you know taste
everything but I can tell you like I'm a
fashion designer
I own a sewing school I'm a realtor and
my day job is I I'm a I'm an IC product
manager I want to quit my job
so bad that I could just taste it mm-hmm
all right now one one of the things I've
been thinking a lot about with quitting
Jobs is are you willing to live a more
humble lifestyle from your expenses that
allow you to quit your job quicker so I
also know your your position kind of
like on real estate so I own my own home
I'm renting a home in DC I want to let
the home in DC like go and just like
live in my current place yes I think I
can like look I think you know I think I
wanna I think one of the biggest ways to
get happy is to stop spending [ __ ] on
dump spot stop spending money on dumb
[ __ ] which allows you to get to a place
where you quit your jobs quicker yeah
yeah okay
you know like I'm very big on this
everybody thinks about making more money
to quit their job I'm thinking about
spending less money on dumb [ __ ] yeah
and I mean I've been doing less of that
and like pouring more into my business
yeah so you know every chance I get I'm
you know like I'm like I'm buying
empathy wine for my sipping clothes and
you know and I've paid off my cars but
most house in DC is sort of like I don't
really need the headache right I need to
focus more on my [ __ ] I get it I get it
that makes a lot of sense to me I look I
think it's about overhead and investment
and you just have to think about how you
want to attack it and what in what time
frame does that make sense yeah that's
it my plan frames are like quit my job
is like a year okay like I just but I
hate it like whatever we quit right now
the only way I can quit right now is by
cutting your overhead okay people can
quit their [ __ ] job quicker if they
pay less and rent and mortgage and stop
buying [ __ ] off whites and go into
Turks and Caicos on vacation
right everybody talks about everybody
talks about making more money nobody
talks about wasting money on dumb [ __ ]
exactly does that make sense yes I mean
you definitely helped me like okay
anything that I made I need to reinvest
into my business and not like you know
happy hours and trip to Miami and like
all the other things that I've been
doing for the last ten years listen
people people are living people are
working [ __ ] jobs to maintain their
lifestyle of short-term [ __ ] that allows
them to escape their unhappiness of
their [ __ ] job it's one [ __ ]
vicious cycle like you're wasting money
on trips and escapism because you don't
love your day to day and like that's
what I'm trying to get people to focus
on which is instead of spending that
money I'll allow yourself to live a
little more humbly which then allows you
to actually love what you do
yeah it's it's very real like I think
about this all the time the amount of
people that were thrilled with life at
87 K that hate their life at a hundred K
because they became the manager in that
company from 87 K to a hundred and they
loved being a doer but they loved being
an Indian but they hated being achieved
on that 13 K but as soon as they got
that 13 K they bought some dumb [ __ ] or
they got a better apartment I think
about this [ __ ] every day
yeah that's what I'm like afraid of like
I'm an icy prophet man good for you by
the way
fun fact only 2.3 percent of Americans
make over 200,000 a year you're probably
in the top 4 to 7 % earners in all of
America isn't that crazy
America's richest countries in the world
and you right now on the phone are
probably in the top seven
because the top nine percent are over a
hundred thousand you're in the top did
you ever realize that you're in the top
seven percent of earners in this entire
country which is one of the richest
countries in the world well I realize
that when I look at my parents who
combined wasn't even making what I make
when they retired love love good for you
but happiness needs to be what we chase
not how much we make each year when I
let me let me tell you something and
this is the realest [ __ ] ever maybe it's
two bottles of rose a in I probably I
probably leave on the table ten to
fifteen million dollars a year when I
make five to ten a year mm-hmm because I
want to be happy and money doesn't make
me happy
now in that everybody who's listening I
[ __ ] you [ __ ] seven eight
million ninety nine company I get it I
get it but I also did it when I was
speaking I just went to Indonesia and I
spoke I made more money in that speech
that I made in the first seven years of
my career combined yeah yeah I mean but
the funny thing is like what's making me
happy is actually like doing what you're
saying like responding to the people who
give it in you know and like being like
super focus on what your community is
saying I think and the moment I did that
like my [ __ ] was just like people were
like oh my classes were sold out and
people were responding 100% to it suck
everybody's so confused I can't wait for
thirty years from now all these [ __ ]
that are spitting hate doing the wrong
thing they're all gonna lose I don't
give a [ __ ] people are so confused
there's so much going on in our culture
right now if you're spitting hey if
you're suppressing somebody if you're
judging somebody you're gonna [ __ ]
lose yep one of my students yesterday
she said oh do you mind if I post like
what you're actually telling us in class
and I'm like I don't care there's money
out here for everyone and so much
abundance so much abundance
I [ __ ] love it I have no courses I
don't want your money do I want you to
buy why yes if you buy wine or you can
use it for gifts or business or [ __ ]
like like [ __ ] if you're
watching my [ __ ] all day long and you
wear sneakers buy my sneakers if that's
cool right like if you drink wine or you
have a strategy of for clients or
business cool but it's not don't write
and that's like what the eyes look
they're like the small three pack and
then I cancelled it and then I got the
720 because I'm like I'm giving my
client free wine every weekend for my
sipping so like why not do this and pour
into my business and support you because
I listen to you [ __ ] every day I love
you for that
by the way I just pinned the comment
from one of my favorite Jets let's talk
about this right now one of my favorite
shots was rookie last year on his first
game he just wrote Tokio [ __ ] bro so in
the first game last year against Detroit
in his rookie year his first game I
think he went to Tulane he'll spit it in
here if I'm right uh-huh he had an
interception I think he wears number 43
I'm think I'm right
Nickerson and he had an interception
they called it incomplete my man for
three I saw it I know that was a pick if
Todd Bowles [ __ ] challenged it you
would have to pick my guy yeah [ __ ]
man I'm super pumped he just [ __ ]
posted in here I love him so much
it is facts my dude that was a pic you
got both feet in I saw it on the replay
I was in Detroit supporting cuz that's
how I [ __ ] with the Jets and I can't
wait to see you [ __ ] shine this year
my guy i'm sad Busters gone busters my
dude I hope he does well in Chicago but
this is gonna be your opportunity to
shine this year I'm looking forward to
the 4-3
anyway thank you for calling I love you
and I appreciate this or I mean it I
love you I'm talking sorry I love you go
Nate Rob give me a long night all right
we don't speed round let's go
it's great when the family's away we can
hustle let's go
yeah Brian pools join the team I saw
that from Atlanta follow the real peak
the real peanut real Phoenix and his
whole family rocking those jerseys hello
this is the first of the speed round
this is the first two speed round what
can I answer for you brother
holy [ __ ] this is intense
just a little context by myself yeah
just got fired last lost my job for
asking my CEO she knew you that was
really bad moving past real quick I know
yeah let's hear it you asked your seal
she knew me she says no and fires you on
the spot didn't know I've a documented
the whole thing uploaded the YouTube
someone at my company saw that it went
viral internally I actually you're blown
up if you do Google turns Gary
Vaynerchuk in Detroit Michigan March 6
you blew up everything it's not
embarrassing no embarrassing you send me
the email with Google Trends in a town
hall you asked and this is like a booty
right I saw this this hit my radar yeah
there was yeah yeah but yeah but now I'm
flipping stuff on Facebook that video
got you fired oh yeah why because you
can't there's no you can't document
anything on campus so like I knew that
like but you I was just you super
excited I was just documenting like hi
pure fire good for you but it was time
you know it was tough to walk away from
such a stable gig but it was time
flippin stuff on Facebook right now
how's it going to start a cannabis it's
going good you know I'm Michael sixty
three dollars a day is half my salary
and I'm pretty much there and just
like the last couple days right I trap
the butter trash very serious note
retailers are closing out JIT and the
closeout aisle scanner that [ __ ] on
Amazon is [ __ ] three times the price
awesome
so starting up a cannabis trimmer retail
companies are rentals and in a
service-based because I can't get into
the regulated space in the cannabis
world you know if you use your working
magic and know who hooked me up with
that'd be awesome but advice for someone
gotten a cannabis yes trimming machine
there's a cannabis agency that I own
called that I'm a partner and excuse me
called Green Street Google Green Street
Gary Vaynerchuk and hit up that agency
once you find the LA Times article about
us I can do that Green Street Green
Street Walla take care of it from there
I'm pretty excited hopefully it'll work
out well anyway just one last thing my
cousin he's he just got drafted he's in
the NFL Andrew Wiley Kansas City Chiefs
just vane I told him to hit up Vayner
source agency but maybe you guys can
reach out to him because that would be
really cool
he family I don't want to be
disrespectful to his current agent but
you can tell them up he if you call him
I mean this is a close cousin or some
weird [ __ ] dissing [ __ ] no no like
yeah we're brothers call him he may be
happy with his agent but if he's not you
tell him to email Gary at Vayner
sports.com and I'll get him proper
uh-huh I will do that awesome well love
you bro I'm giving the wait yeah he's
gonna put the wine into my parents so
thank you brother
talk to you have a good one Payless I
love you so much so pay less flip is
ridiculous pay let get in here sit here
right now so get in here it's [ __ ] no
vice yo who's this hey Lucas Lucas it's
Gary Vaynerchuk give me one second sit
tell everybody who Robert you're new to
the team go ahead
hi I'm Daniel Daniel tell them about
your flip like your fifth strategy
Payless is closing you can't buy it
online you can only get in stores
they've shut everything down but you can
buy a ton of stuff like forty sixty
percent off have you done a flip yet so
give me a give me a Saturday flip that's
exciting
so I New Jersey and no high school they
love doing it she's doing great content
we have an Amazon we have a Oprah
LinkedIn Instagram tomorrow that you're
gonna see all her good and gonna flip it
online for probably 18 on Amazon how
many did you buy about five so you
bought five at 30 and you think five
we're gonna go for about ninety yeah I
love you thank you yeah your [ __ ]
trap and flip Bob I [ __ ] love that
[ __ ] alright bro how are you good it
Gary good it was thank you so much for
supporting the the wine club no
absolutely I think it I mean I'll
probably you know I'll probably give
away 33 bottles and try each one myself
and see ya not too much but cool
what can I answer for your clients and
friends what can I answer um so I know
it's kind of a lightning round but I
just wanted to say I really appreciate
your content of course everybody's
saying that it's fantastic you put out
so much and I just appreciate it thank
you I particularly like your stuff
around like when you're when you're just
kind of riffing on education okay and
not not like higher education in college
and that kind of stuff I understand your
stance there but like other types of
education you know like future okay um
for for context I'm a copywriter direct
response not a not content or anything
like that and I train junior writers in
a very like small way and hearing you
riff on education and then trying to do
that for my
they'll kind of like I just want to know
what your perspective is on what
education should look like or like craps
and for you know professions and that
sort of thing like especially these a
little bit more like a little bit in
quant create and a little bit in
creative and that kind of thing so so
that's where my head's at
I apologize give me one second brother
boy you might hear my dog squeal and
she's at she's excited to hear your
voice too no worries alright one more
time I apologize I had to just text
somebody go ahead well so nutshell I'm a
copywriter and I train writers and I
train in small groups yep um but I focus
on direct response stuff okay and I
consider it to be a profession and a
craft and something you get better at
because it is because of Emily 100% is
right and so you know with your
perspective on education and getting
better at a craft overtime and all that
kind of stuff where do you see the
future of that the future of that
profession specifically because you riff
on copywriters a little bit in your
content and you just emphasize the
importance but then it's kind of like I
think we hit that wall was like it's
important but it's so contextual to each
business and so you know specific to
each industry that you typically go much
further when you're just riffing so
what's your perspective on education I
guess in in the very near future and
also on copywriters specifically and
knowing that it has to be like I
couldn't I couldn't be more bullish on
education right like I think being
educated and having knowledge is
incredibly important rest in peace
King Kong Bundy who just passed recently
um I just don't like the current state
of how its packaged and the costs mm-hmm
I couldn't be more passionate about the
current state of copywriting because I
think it's a grossly underestimated
skill set and so that's kind of where um
where I'm at which is like like I just
genuinely believe that
education matters I just hate the way
that it's being packaged and sold and
one of the reasons I put out so much
content for free is I'm trying to put
pressure on the system a against people
that sell for seven two thousand four
$700 or two thousand dollar courses when
I'm putting up better information for
free and then the fact the matter is
there's not a single class in college
right now teaching marketing that holds
a [ __ ] candle to the [ __ ] I'm putting
out on the day yeah this is for free
yeah 100% especially you know like a
marketing major going to be you comms
major and you're paying [ __ ] 67,000 a
year and there's like this dick face in
New York putting out content every day
for free cheap and you're in for 250 in
debt for education about 1997 marketing
and I'm putting out the 2019 marketing
for free that's a brain [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's broken I mean it Jahna 57 year old
parent that wants you to go to bu
because they want to put a bumper
sticker on their [ __ ] like you know
on their car to look good and meanwhile
ready mad at me cuz I drop an f-bomb
like that's what I'm fascinated about
culture oh yeah well so why do you so
why do you say copywriting is
underestimate or like undervalue and I'm
a practitioner and I know how much copy
matter
I literally just scolded my team and not
scolded cuz we're soul of year but like
telling them that like it stopped trying
to write the titles on the mean content
at the top send me the raw video let me
write the copy because the thumbnail and
the mean title to our content is the
difference between 300,000 views and 1.7
million views and that matters for brand
awareness right but you're the one doing
that you're the one writing it right cuz
I'm coming for the home part yeah I mean
I that's right now I probably you know I
I'm so busy that probably like six out
of ten headlines that you see on
Instagram are coming from my team but
the reality is yeah that's costing me
and one of the things we just talked
about tonight before I went live is I
want to do the titles yeah copyright cop
is one of the single I'm actually
thinking about hiring 70 so one of the
things I think are happening that
nobody's talking about is ageism so
we're talking about sexism right we're
talking about racial issues the thing
we're not talking about in this digital
world is the massive disrespect to
somebody 50 and older we talk about
women minorities being suppressed I
think there's a massive disrespect for
people 50 to 90 years old one of the big
agendas I have at vaynermedia is hiring
sixty seventy eighty nine year olds
there used to be copywriters for the old
Mad Men era and hiring them for
vaynermedia cuz I think they're better
at their craft and a lot of 33 year olds
I think they're [ __ ] hot [ __ ] oh hell
yeah like especially if you get some of
the guys who were really deep in direct
mail and the big camp are you kidding
I'm 90% it yeah no there's a woman I met
that 73 years old that would run [ __ ]
rings around everybody that works a
veiner but at Vayner everybody on the
west coast and east coast are super
socially liberal but they're completely
ageism because they're part of the tech
world and part of this new age so they
think like a 71 year old doesn't know
how to use filters on Instagram but
they're completely [ __ ] and this is the
conversation I want to bring to the
forefront for sure no I totally agree I
mean some of the best writers that I've
I've seen been like even like so they
started like in journalism or something
and then they let me bro they'll make
that three ounce of cereal the number
one underrated talent in our society
today is not minorities and women it's
people 60 to 90 years old yeah by the
way women and minorities are underrated
as well but the number one underrated
people in the current state are 60 to 90
year olds
it's an ageism issue right now on top of
a racial and gender issue but the ageism
is completely on Full Tilt yeah well I
mean you're talking about hiring four
agencies
I mean what about that like people like
me like I freelance so so what about
that route I mean one thing to go
internal that's another thing to go you
know when you're in control all of it
right it's macro yeah I just I mean I
feel like there's more opportunity on
the freelance route yes you don't have
to deal with that Dubai girls
if the freelancer outs amazing if you're
willing to have the anxiety of going
paycheck to paycheck that's true by the
way Joey Fatone I see you in the
comments one of the [ __ ] iconic by
the way watching the Jonas Brothers have
a hit right now like I really think in
sync but actually but like contemporary
honestly they're they're doing great
with like the classics but like what's
amazing about being a brand at any point
is you're always one song away from
being relevant again and so I watched
like some of the classics this is my big
beef with Billy Joel and Elton John like
put out new music news and do a
collaboration with like little keyed and
gonna and [ __ ] you know tear a wack
like there's a way for them to hack it
anyway nonetheless just on my mind big
fan of joe joe Fidel's [ __ ] talented
that my Greek Wedding Broadway like just
a [ __ ] charismatic lovable [ __ ]
character I see him in the [ __ ]
Instagram right now so want to give him
love anyway bro you got this like you
got it down yeah hey Karen I appreciate
your time thanks again Tom have a good
one hey we might have to do a separate
session [ __ ] minimott here picking up
at like 6:00 a.m. work out everybody
watching right now got Twitter and tell
everybody that if they're not [ __ ]
part of our community they're [ __ ]
idiot
right May Marty hello Marty Oh Gary be
your let you do that I'm actually lit
tonight like I actually put a match and
I blew on it the whole [ __ ] world
would explode that's exactly right
big shout out to King Kong [ __ ] Bundy
dude uh rest in peace
what can I answer for you alright so
give you just some quick context so
eighth grade dropout yeah that guy for
web I learned the web trade during a web
developer position when I was 13 someone
taught me the ropes got bored of it went
into marketing tried starting on my own
company maybe four or five
fales huge when in the retail opened up
some locations and kiosks and decided to
go wholesale failed and now I got up a
marketing contract last year that drill
up some business
about a million bucks for this Granite
Company down the road and at the end of
the year they told me they didn't want
it because it wasn't their customer so I
said well I'll go after it then so I
opened up the showroom last Monday
selling cabinets and countertops and uh
you know now here I am a weekend to it
we freaked and killed it week one and
now I'm trying to figure out you know
which direction go ahead and do I just
crush the competition by being cheaper
because I don't have the overhead or yep
yeah price is a great short-term
arbitrage okay
the end if you don't have the over it
like one of the reasons wine library
became huge was because I didn't pay
myself more than fifty thousand over the
first eight years even I took it from
three to forty five million okay you
understand yeah
no I got through humility and living
humble is the single biggest advantage
for small businesses from going to small
to large
the biggest reason most people don't big
bill bit don't bid don't build big
businesses is because as soon as they
have a little momentum they bump they
buy a [ __ ] Mercedes do you understand
what I don't need sixty million I didn't
change my lifestyle let me say it one
more time for the kids in the back when
I was building Boehner
excuse me wine library from three to
sixty million I did not change my
lifestyle I went to [ __ ] Jakarta
Indonesia this weekend last weekend and
made more money than I made in the first
seven years of my career combined
because as I built my dad's business
from three to sixty million I didn't
change my salary that's not fair I went
from 35 to 40
into 45 to 50 thousand in that
seven-year window I started vaynermedia
at 34 years old leaving my family
business that I built from 3 to 60
million in the conference room of
another company because I had no money
all these trolls that go into my
comments that say don't listen to Gary
he was given three million dollars are
reading headlines and don't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about they're
bad excuses I went into my family
business worked my [ __ ] face off from
22 to 34 for 12 years gave up my entire
social life gave up every weekend gave
up any leisure and fun spent 12 years
and build my family business from 3 to
60 million and left with nothing because
I owned none of the [ __ ] business and
I never paid myself more than a hundred
K at the apex mainly I paid myself fifty
thousand because I invested all the
money back into the business that was
the only way to get it from three to
sixty but all the [ __ ] that are
watching right now as soon as they get a
little something they buy dumb [ __ ] and
they don't reinvest in their [ __ ]
business right and you know right now we
know we've been living we kind of
sacrifice and we're living with you know
my in-laws we don't pay ourselves and
just kind of throw everything back there
yes
leave it out them in live dirtier you
want to build something big live [ __ ]
dirtier live dirtier everybody thinks
their business pays them I'm paying the
business yep I'm feeding the [ __ ]
business
sweet well we played out drinking this
wine and my wine it left my wife is a
huge wine fan so I'm excited to get it
I'm humbled by your support brother
means the [ __ ] world to me yeah man
without install you in DC I think it was
a January baby yeah sounds right yeah
your ad Robert Herjavec and that was a
good one I [ __ ] brought it that day
yeah sweet man
thank you brother I appreciate it up I
appreciate it thank you bro let's keep
it going
listen people composed humility is the
foundation success vote yeah
Marcus Dori its Gary Vaynerchuk oh my
god Gary my man how are you I'm [ __ ]
tired as [ __ ] but I'm fired - [ __ ] up
because I'm so grateful for you buying
three cases of this [ __ ] amazing wine
you are seriously first of all you're a
huge inspiration I want to just thank
you and tell you our smooth gratitude I
know everyone saying that you somebody
and I can't believe when you're still
there you're still working you're still
drinking wine which is awesome and I'm
excited I apologize brother how many
packs let myself you know I'm sorry I
apologize three case orders oh right I'm
sitting here yep this is like the most
Mennonite of everything I believe in
right if you think about my career where
I'm at the leverage I have the business
I own the network I have the money I
have the opportunity I have the leverage
I have
I'm sitting here tonight for the last
[ __ ] four hours and there are
questions I feel the hundred cases of
wine a hundred um yeah I need to sell
twenty five thousand yeah I've sold a
hundred call by call by call bro a
hundred I need sell twenty five thousand
human you know humility is the
foundation of long term success I I
gotta tell you I thought I was gonna
miss your call because I'm in Times
Square and my band that I managed is
doing a photoshoot it's like 40 degree
30 degrees out and they're like half
dress and I just got done with it I'm
like and my wife called me she's like he
just called someone and they didn't
answer it was probably like just don't
babe I've been listening all right and
then you call me after we just got done
it's unbelievable
and I think like
everything that you're doing like all I
do all day long if I own my own business
and I bump down like if I'm just not
feeling right I just check in with you
and all I got to do is watch one of your
videos and that helps me through the day
let me tell you something I should go
see a census for $200 an hour it's
hitting her room for 40 minutes or $200
an hour okay I can go to one of your
videos and works 45 seconds and that's
gonna switch my whole day that's gonna
switch my whole day I guess that's what
you're doing I'm somebody you know dude
brother I'm trying to treat I'm fyke I'm
[ __ ] trying to change and break the
entire [ __ ] framework yeah like it's
like if you don't like like I'm on some
legacy [ __ ] yep
you know what I mean yep I watch you
you're you didn't you did a podcast with
my friend Chad big tall guy Chad yeah
that's Marilyn yep yep it was so
inspiring to just you know again just
listening to your game plan and talking
about how many people you want to touch
in your life like how many and it's just
I don't know that people actually really
understand you're going for I mean it's
all of it and bro and what are you doing
it what are you doing you you do your
[ __ ] come on bike home dude when I
tell you I sit here today in my gut in
my [ __ ] heart then oh like that I
haven't even started like I'm a young
hero I'm at zero you don't think people
understand like I'm it did I haven't
[ __ ] started I I literally think I'm
like 15 years like right I know that 99%
of the world doesn't know who I am I
know that if I get hit a buy-bust
tonight I get a trending topic on
Twitter tomorrow for four to seven hours
some love my latest comment on Instagram
will have a hundred thousand comments
and then Albert don't be it like when
you know you mean nothing but you aspire
to be everything you go from opposite
directions at a level that nobody's ever
seen before that's my [ __ ] framework
if I I'm blessed if I'm blessed with
health
if I'm blessed with health I'm [ __ ]
going for yeah I'm going health is that
were nothing without health or nothing
without help and let me tell you could
have ran through these phone calls
tonight Gary you know you could have hit
on the phone second you didn't do that
but bro bro you're gonna love this
this is a comment that I see on my
screen Kent wanna says Gary is an
arrogant fool who's disrespecting this
caller what but bro that's like like
honestly like that's like you know I'm
gonna pin his tweet because I think in
the desert and I'm not razzing I'm
fascinated by Kent wonho's comment like
what are you doing up at midnight
leaving a comment that says I'm an AI
Oregon fool disrespecting this caller
like I don't think that's a troll I
don't think that's a hater
I process in my head in the fascination
of why one sees that and then I go into
empathy this is why we call it empathy I
go try to figure it out what Kent wanto
is going through in his life that
compels him to leave that government
fascinated by this [ __ ] yeah and that's
the honestly because flipped it you can
you know some people are gonna get mad
upset at what you know but you're trying
to look at the other side where is this
person coming from what makes them do
that I'm not mad at wha no like I don't
feel like the pain I I don't feel the
pain for me I feel the pain
not that I feel the pain for them it
could be like a 15 year old kid that's
just looking for attention I don't know
anything right no you don't know you
can't go fascinated by the world like
I'm fascinated by that [ __ ] right like
yeah I don't know anyway ma'am anything
I want to I want to tell you one thing
my money I'm not gonna ask you I'm not
gonna ask you a question I'm not gonna
ask you a question because you've been
answer so many questions for me without
me even asking you but I just want to I
just want to offer you I want to say one
thank you I managed these bands some
people in your office probably I've
heard of them once called Jessie's Girl
they do a whole TV show the other ones
called the fresh to the bel-air they do
a whole 90 show they both do weekly
shows in cities but I just want to make
it all for you
both of those bands are they're pretty
like things still out shows you if you
don't mind you'll see them they play the
capital paramount you know they do
weekly shows in New York City I just
want to make this offer to you pay
everything and you don't need to you
don't need to announce it you don't need
to say I or anybody okay I want to offer
any of my band if you don't mind my
website ml presents calm and I'll
present Market Market
yep-yep ml present if you go and see my
bands and it I will my bands get fifteen
to twenty five thousand dollars show I
will donate my bad bit any no no
[ __ ] please just ask Gary do you
ever come to New York City I live in New
York City I work out of New York City go
ahead brother if anybody goes no no no
if you you go on my thing I don't care
if it's two weeks from now six months
from now a year from now if you want any
of my band I will deliver them free not
one dime I don't care if it's for a
charity if it's for your sister's
wedding if it's for your best friend's
engagement party I will deliver my band
I'm not kidding you'll see how really oh
not a die email me again right at
vaynermedia calm yep
and we're gonna figure some I'll have
them play at a Boehner event just to
give you whatever you want whatever you
are if you want to tell me your office
if you wanted them to come to your
office and play for your staff and pump
them up with 80s or 90s music for an
hour like walk like an Egyptian is my
[ __ ] jam Jessie's Girl I mean they
did Neil Patrick Harris his 40th
birthday I mean they're the real deal
you'll see them but that's my offer to
you and out of time and sent and I'm and
yeah I wanna go I'm uncomfortable with
being given I want to give him return if
you've been watching tonight what buddy
spend 7:20 I'm trying to figure out how
to give them 7,200 270 mm semi an email
we're gonna use it and we're gonna get
focus poser up the [ __ ] ass but Gary
[ __ ] I know but I'll tell you I swear
to God if you tell anybody I've ever
made you that offer I will deliver that
[ __ ] to you for nothing because you know
what when you
right-click club on everybody's [ __ ]
face
you remember coffee club all right I'm a
pole I'm a [ __ ] pop-culture [ __ ]
savant people are sleeping on my [ __ ]
skills I know more [ __ ] about [ __ ]
America than [ __ ] America how many
more phones you gotta [ __ ] do we only
need [ __ ] more Rosie I'm gonna come
around you know too much send me an
email
see ya all right Nate get the next one
we have like they go around taking
[ __ ] please if you're watching this
is entertain you at all at least a three
pack subscription hello wines that come
grace hello it's Gary
hi Gary I was just about to go to bed
well wait I'm [ __ ] off grace I want I
gotta wake everybody else you [ __ ] up
too because I'm telling you the speed
round skill me I love you I'm sorry I'm
trying to go faster but I'm going slow
no I love you I love you more grace for
you and everybody's watching who ordered
we're gonna clearly have to need another
session and Nate and I will work
together to allocate an hour in the next
10 business days to call everybody in
film well go ahead and grease yeah I'm
glad you said that right before our
caucus they're all logging off not a bit
about him on the East Coast is 12
[ __ ] midnight they're like number 20
on the [ __ ] list of 27 people we have
to be empathetic I understand completely
so first of all if everybody said thank
you for being so freaking amazing I
absolutely love it I love everything you
do Zig Zig Zig dude fan also um you know
my one question is is there any way I
could ever get on stage with you on
stick will talk to me about why so I've
made my money I'm an entrepreneur real
happy love my life and I get a thrill
out of
helping other people love their life to
you well you know I don't know because a
lot of times I don't control the stage
but what I would tell you to definitely
do based on the vibe here is you should
go to Bainer speakers I don't know if
you know about Vayner speakers something
we just started ah you should probably
you know CC me Gary at vaynermedia comm
and maybe there's something we can dig
into and figure it out I love it thank
you so much you're welcome thank you so
much okay love you bye bye okay hold on
one more second this person saying
classes our program for business world
that's nice
that's nice is a good reply its her push
back that I'm wrong about college yes
look first of all here's the reply first
of all none of the content I put out in
the macro is a one size fits all
nothing is makes me happier than seeing
you have this comment I have a funny
feeling in 10 years when you come back
to this comment being in the trenches
will teach you way more we're shrunk
marks bad and we're ours nor a [ __ ]
Mick Theo's hustling what are they
playing [ __ ] fortnight or something
I'm confused are they working good okay
you're my favorite hello Geoffrey it's
Gary [ __ ] Vaynerchuk yeah out of town
I'm Anne I'm leaving town immediately
you got to be kidding me
where you from you are almond
Jacksonville North Carolina I've
traveled the world let's go bro thank
you so much for supporting me everybody
tonight who buys empathy wines calm is
my family it means the world to me
I have 25,000 [ __ ] cases to sell I've
sold 5,000 so you can just imagine I got
work to do yeah don't be that's crazy
I am Wow dope beats list thank you bro
what can I guess I appreciate the call
nah just uh no I just want to let you
know I mean you've already done enough
for me in your perspective man you a lot
of your stuff I just wanna talk to you
about perspective and how you've changed
my perspective in a sentence then please
just uh you uh
I remember one show I watched changed my
life I tell my art I already knew but
like your show just really really did
numbers I mean you said uh put the coin
that was your response to someone like
they were like time out looking back and
so on and so forth with the calling
don't look back I remember ever since
like what I remember that yeah ever
since I saw that it was about December
2014
um I flipped the coin with me and my
kids I'm a single parent just me and my
kids and I've never looked back no
regret like people people overthink dumb
[ __ ] because they think somebody's
watching nobody's watching one of the
great well that is bro one of the great
things I've been thinking a lot about is
the audacity of people thinking other
people care yeah file level that I'm at
one of the reasons I tell everybody that
when I die that I'll get a half a day on
social media and everybody will move on
is to try to help everybody realize that
nobody means jack [ __ ] no the second you
realize nobody gives a [ __ ] like they
got their own [ __ ] problems you can
live [ __ ] free yes I don't know
that's that ego or - so you think
anybody gives a [ __ ] about my [ __ ]
life they [ __ ] amen to that and that's
that's the I have never been happy I've
lived a happy life don't get me wrong I
can love my life a lot my kid but that
perspective right there that nobody
gives a [ __ ] when you actually truly
accept that life is so much better
because you don't care and it doesn't
mean the world's bad
there's plenty no not at all whole don't
give a [ __ ] but in the macro in the
macro for everybody who's watching right
now that lost a loved one think about
the fact that you might have lost a
mother father even the worst child and
then a year later you're living your
life that's how humans roll I don't have
any audacity to think I'm special I
think you do right [ __ ] that 5.4 million
followers of Instagram they miss me dick
it means nothing it's [ __ ] definitely
do you understand me chill but no I
understand I you've made a world of
difference but um I just had to I do
have a question so I mean you've already
done so much but I want to give you a
quick background so I just I've got a
career right now I joined the military
at 18 I've been in for about 15 years
and realistically I could retire in five
more years and I'll retire at 38 you
still be young like that that's pretty
cool truth but but the reality of it is
a I might like it much Linda I love what
I've done with my life but I'm ready to
I'm ready to move on I'm tired of I'm
tired it's been 15 years ago parent so
what I did was my my daughter bless her
soul she she she
Nelda and she wanted to make cake pops
okay and I [ __ ] you not like I was
alright cool we'll make cake pops
December 14th
we have been making less than no less
than oh my god that we have made no less
than a hundred cake pops a week I've
invested I call an investment I've
invested about 2.5 k we've made back
about 1.5 K serum right now wasn't what
I'm down a thousand but III if you look
at the numbers the first month I was
down negative 735 December January I was
down negative of negative 500
February I was down negative 200 right
now I'm March I'm up positive 300 so
because I did what you said
I did what you said that's exactly right
keep talkin preach good because because
what you did what I did is I listened to
you that's all I do is listen to you
it's my use Facebook I'm on a single
parent in the military I use that to my
advantage and I just I advertise that
and it's but there's no the in state you
don't want to help people I know I know
that it's a double edged tour but I went
on Instagram like you said and I just
would search Jacksonville random people
every night I make it a goal no more no
less than 20 people on Instagram random
people / hashtag for price tag would go
on how do you hide you look big - I did
hashtag that no every night no less than
20 people could you post it on Instagram
or 10% you will go out there and do this
or 60% he will stop 40% won't like I'm
the one that keeps going work and now my
kids and I have a Facebook page in less
than two months we're up to 218 likes
and that's just it's this great if this
is listening you bro all we gotta do is
listen you will don't have to ask you we
tell a little bit putting out the ship
of free [ __ ] have to execute
that's all I got to do that's all and
that's like that's what I wanted to say
I appreciate you've changed perspective
like you you're doing great things like
I think that's the best thing I do for
you is just let you know that what
you're doing is working because last
thing I'll get off I know you got a lot
of people phone calls to make
but recently in the past two weeks
people have hit me up in my community
saying hey I don't want to insult you or
your kids but we respect what you've
been doing and we were just one
how you got started how did you start
your business can we start selling our
cakes
do you mind if I do that like and just
reminding that episode you said when
people start copying you you've made it
I'm only like four months in but I'm
just listening all this perspective and
all this preaching you do it's it it's
real talk you gotta execute brother I
know bro the amount of people the
thousands of people that take my content
repackage it and then sell it and think
that I'm a sucker is way more than you
can ever imagine they're just confused
because they're running sprints and I'm
running marathons you know I didn't know
I'd be here with the doomed I know what
I'm about I know you understand you
through I'm proud of you bro kidding
I'll keep pushing thank you thank you
doing a I'm happy you spot for you and
I'm so grateful for you to buy oh that
was ocean sorry that wine so I got to
talking about flip last thing I promised
the flip go future flip hasn't happened
yet that one you just think I was
wondering why I'm I do it cuz I quit
drinking however however these cake pops
I'm making I recently made some rum cake
so these wine bottles yeah easily
I could easily make some wine cake pops
you easily delete you make the wine
k-pops and email me I will give it loved
and change the course of your business I
know it's gonna happen it's not nice
it's when know what do I value it Gary
at vaynermedia calm area vaynermedia to
come all right I will send you an email
and I'll let you know when I got that
wine once I receive the line I'll make
the cake pot love you bro good luck
thank you I may throw up I don't get
drunk ever I'm actually fairly ok with a
little buzzed you you look like do you
rock a little bit awesome but other than
that it's funny a lot of people talk
about management yeah you know not being
the are and a lot of people didn't a lot
of people assumed listen
interesting you replied right yo Tyler
its Gary B who Tyler yeah sorry it's
Gary [ __ ] Vaynerchuk oh [ __ ]
first of all things about I'm Tyler
thank you so [ __ ] much for buying
Club empathy yeah you're welcome dude it
means a lot to me dude it really means a
lot to me I can tell like dude I got 25
[ __ ] thousand kids you know I'm not
sitting here a [ __ ] jerk of myself
off for four hours
I got [ __ ] work to do bro I've sold
100 cases in four hours
like I get paid yeah and 200,000 offices
paid for an hour like nice really [ __ ]
me here like I got work to do you got a
lot of work to do
did I so much work to do and it's great
right because I think people think you
get fancy and you don't have the
community humility like I'm about to
work you know yeah the people that are
watching like they don't understand how
an order right now even a three pack if
you don't work it I don't think God
people understand how much nine bottles
at 27 bucks a bottle
means the [ __ ] world to me yeah I can
tell you then I think it's great
obviously it's named empathy because you
care so I would think so much my
audience can't afford 720 yeah you know
so I get it like I get it I'm thankful
for anybody who can what can I get
what can answer for you oh okay here we
go
normally in the comic offi donut fast
just I'd love to sell 500 cases at our
festivals figure it out [ __ ] out go
ahead bro whoa can I lose at twelve
sixteen five our people are waking up in
Europe now we're looking for people to
buy a thousand cases in like Europe
Germany London if you're one of those
ballers emailed me at Gary at
vaynermedia calm go ahead bro I
apologize yeah no that's fine man so a
lot of your content is kind of related
to some b2b I
growing your own brands you know social
media type stuff and I love it when lots
for me though it seems a little bit
different so I'm looking for a little
bit direction very applicable to what I
do build badass cars on yes design
prototype and production of composite
parts right now okay um
and we took a chevy corvette made a wide
body kit for it completely redesigned it
made it sickest [ __ ] okay really going
to pioneer the trends of this car
becoming one of the hottest cars
modified in the future here okay and i'm
just going to see kind of some insight
of where you thought up how to start
kicking that off and getting some people
to fall in love with this thing i would
be em influencers around the people that
would be most likely to be paying
attention to what you're doing yeah I
think Instagram has the attention of
this audience at scale yes attack that
yeah exactly and what do you think then
like because I thought a few ideas as
far as like doing like a build with
maybe some youtubers or something where
we actually build a kit for them come
help me build the car you know and
document the whole transformation of
this I would DM a bunch of influencers
on in Cerreta and have over a million
followers and find out how they would
like like ask them how they would like
to collaborate okay instead of come in
what's up brother over a million follow
you yell Vermillion because they wanted
warts they're tipping because it's a lot
of work for you right there right but in
in related to cars that's right okay
alright can you ask flat-out like what
would you like to do right right and I
kind of figured you would say that
so maybe quicker lyrics you know dig a
little bit deeper when it comes to like
the custom automotive round
what would you say other than social
media to try to really get down dirty
well what do you let's work backwards
what are you trying to accomplish like
overall yeah I would say my legs should
be somewhat like Christopher von
Koenigsegg in the hypercar market so
what end consumer do you think really
brings you the most value
well yes we're at right now to where
that would be would be completely
different right now before you worry
about your macro long-term ambitions you
need to exit of what's in front of you
right so that's important it yep you bet
so right now if you guys that are very
interested in the modifying cars you
know eat sleep breathe cars and are
willing to spend and take a little bit
of time you know you know I say a fair
amount of time to build the cart and
spend probably well over $100,000
transforming so where is that community
living like in in in in forums in in
YouTube like where do you think that
like forums feels like a real place
where that community is playing out yeah
yeah I'd say it's pretty popular there
huh and also on Instagram I would
definitely say there's a lot going on
with that yeah I mean I'm a huge fan of
DMing on Instagram I feel like there's
so much [ __ ] business development
happening in there right right right
and so I definitely agree that real
quick I apologize back on let's get that
distribution in Kentucky a thousand
cases easy this is on Twitter Nora on
Twitter
Paul Blackburn at Paul black burn he's
talking about a thousand cases easy in
Kentucky we need to follow that lead
Paul Blackburn really kentucky's gonna
say we can strip - what about a
distributor I apologize buddy thousand
keys in Kentucky got me excited good
yeah yeah no that's fine um so yeah kind
of going to the next thing is one thing
that I know you know kind of doubling
down on what I'm good at
I've been struggling with the website I
do a lot you know but trying to focus on
what I'm really good at you know I was
trying to think of how I could reach out
to kind of collaborate with some guys
that are looking to help develop our
website so we can really push some of
this product smart so how you thinking
about doing that well kind of like you
were saying hitting some people up on
Instagram and stuff and our vertical
honestly I'm shocked by how many people
are hungry and wants something in life
and are not spending two to three hours
a day
sending custom emails on LinkedIn and
DMing custom things on Instagram I'm
just shocked right right right
like it alone I used to spend eleven
hours a day seven hours a day four hours
a day on Instagram I excuse me on
Twitter in 2007 to 2011 just engaging
right right yep and I and I've been
really Drive that lately trying to
handle everything else you know and
that's kind of where I figured if I'm
not generating the time I need to kind
of collaborate with somebody that
actually did it done agreed
then you think though it'd be fine with
somebody that's not located within our
vicinity 100% and what on that then what
do you feel that would be a value to
them you just blast them you ask them
what they value I'm searching for what
if I was and like hashtags got it then
yep and then the next thing I would say
is you just talked to the take to CEO
yeah I mean we have the ability to and
and really would love to build the cart
from the Gran Turismo franchise cuz they
would seriously be amazing for them to
promote I mean email us or Phyllis set
it up and in trying to like think of
think kind of like around what you
talked about like people were taking
selfies in front of the thing would make
it feel like they wouldn't again you
know send me an email I'll send it up a
hundred percent I will do Gary I love
you bro thank you I'll finish up their
energy thank you
alright let's keep it going are you
talking about the Arab macro micro
12:13 above all right but then like I
like I'm my sauce to be sustainable
there's still 20 how many people
alright cuz we're gonna do everybody
watching cuz you're probably falling
asleep we're gonna capture this is gonna
be last one will capture everybody else
we'll send them an email I'm gonna
scatter hi this is Eric Eric its Gary
Vaynerchuk oh my god Gary how are you
man he's amazing
are you star you silver enough yet at
all I'm you know what's funny bro I am
actually slightly sobering up now it's
just [ __ ] late holy [ __ ] dude it is
great to talk to you again
I saw you in Phoenix a couple months ago
I was one of those nine people in the
room that got two hours with you that's
awesome bro did you enjoy that oh it was
awesome I'm the guy that sign guy that
made that sign for you and then in
business with my dad we were on Gary Vee
I remember you very vividly brother
Thank You Man I you know what I just
want to thank you for all you've done
the advice that you gave me in that room
I started doing advertising and and it's
working man it's it's working my
subscriber rates going up the sales are
going up it's working just like you said
it would you know what's funny I say
this all the time I'm gonna say one last
time before I get out of here
the business advice I give is similar to
fitness advice around hey Gary
I like to get into better shape and I
say workout daily obviously some stretch
days you know obviously your body can
only you know so much and extremely well
healthy
it's not gonna be pills it's not some
weird exercise that's not sustainable
do the right things that's my business
advice and it's super exciting for me to
see certain people that then go and
execute it and actually get the results
you know what I mean yeah
yeah well you know and like we talked
about in the room you know advice is
great but if you don't put it into play
it ain't worth nothing you know if you
don't look good nothing my free advice
is vulnerable to your execution yeah the
reason I absolutely every single day is
I
for my legacy and vulnerable to you
actually acting on the advice that I
give
abso-freakin'-lutely man I agree on a
percent work when you don't do it right
and unfortunately I think there's a huge
huge amount of people that listen to
your advice but they do nothing with it
a lot of people use me for motivation
which is a short-term fix
instead of execution which I'm putting
out every day I keep writing people stop
watching what I say and start executing
on what I do absolutely it's gonna be
twenty six in the morning I'm live on
four different social networks
I have 25,000 cases to sell I've sold a
hundred tonight over four hours well
I'll tell you what man I don't drink
wine I've never liked it but you know if
I was ever gonna start drinking wine I
figured I'm gonna give yours a shot
fortunately my wife likes wine so she'll
probably be drinking most of it or if it
turns out I like it I'll start drinking
it but worst case scenario I'll give it
to give it to customers bro when I tell
you that we produced a forty to fifty
dollar wine that when you give it to
clients and customers it's gonna make
you look tremendous like the amount of
businesses the amount of entrepreneurs
watching tonight that for seven hundred
twenty dollars a year a could subscribe
right now for the three-pack which is
like twenty seven twenty seven fifty
four what's at fifty four seventy eighty
four eighty three eighty one one of the
things that I think is one of the great
arbitrage is is that tonight everybody's
watching can go to empathy wines calm
and spend eighty one dollars to buy the
3-pack subscription and buy it for a
client
do we have notes Nate when people buy
but is it in the slick on the website
like my big thing here's my big thing on
subscription gifts if I'm a business
person watching tonight for eighty one
dollars you go buy a three pack
subscription for like
five clients and that means that three
times a year they get a package in the
mail that makes them think of you and if
you have a business for eighty one
dollars it's cheap it's super cheap it's
beyond sheep for you to hit up like if
you go and take your top ten clients and
go to empathy wines calm right now and
buy it
$81 subscription the confidence I have
that you'll get eight hundred ten
dollars back in business because come
the summer or come the fall when they
get the three pack of the red and it's
from you and then they think of you and
then they do a five thousand dollar
thing with you like people don't invest
in their businesses and it just doesn't
make any sense it's you know I didn't
even know about that the whole buying
the sneakers thing in order to get a
phone call with you but then when I saw
this tonight for seven hundred twenty
bucks you're actually getting a product
and to be able to get on the phone with
you oh my god it's it's a best deal
around math so I'm so here's my here's
my question I want to come over to four
D's in LA and as a matter of fact I got
an email from your guy do you know about
the 10,000 to 12,000 dollar swing the
big that Sasha group is about to switch
well yes I know it so in order to get to
10 grand I got to do it by by the end of
the month right that's right
right so you know I don't I don't really
I just don't know I'm gonna scrape the
money together however I can cuz I
definitely want to be there I've been
talking to Nick a little bit through
leap through email and then I got it
email from somebody else let me say this
it's a good piece of advice if you have
to scrape to get to ten thousand I'd
rather you wait a year and comfortably
get to 12 thousand okay like we'd love
that
well you we'd love to have you but and
listen I've never been more confident
four DS we have all like Nick I see Nick
in the background I [ __ ] love Nick
he's eating [ __ ] cereal like we've
never been more confident about the ten
thousand dollar investment because we
now have so many case studies of people
that we [ __ ] case studies of people
making millions of dollars it's crazy
but I personally as the CEO would rather
you comfortably in 18 months get the
twelve thousand then it's great to get
the ten you understand I understand but
what two chances in eighteen months that
it's up to fifteen or twenty my question
I don't know I don't want to [ __ ]
you but I'll you know I know I'll tell
you this a lot of times eighteen months
later twenty is easier than ten yeah
yeah that's the that's just you know
that's kind of the Delta that's the
decision I have to make yeah that's this
is you have to make now the question
becomes and we've experienced this and I
see Nick in the background there's a lot
of people that scrape ten thousand
together and then that was the thing
that helped them get to a place that
changed the course of their careers so
you know right I don't know I will say
this though me personally I'm more
comfortable about 12-thousand being
easier than ten thousand being scraping
yeah yeah you understand I make two
hundred fifty thousand dollars to give a
speech when when Sasha group gets ten
thousand ahead and four four DS or
twelve thousand I make like eighteen
bucks okay you coming and coming to four
DS and at four months later being like
[ __ ] I had to scrape to that and it
didn't bring me value because you didn't
get value out of that
that's a vulnerability for my brand that
I don't want for eighteen [ __ ]
dollars well I you know I say that and
and in fact is because of the advice
that I've put into play and executed
that you gave me two years ago because
of that my business is tripled and I do
have the money I can do it it's just a
matter of whether I justified
then dude this goes back to the thing
that [ __ ] with everybody I give so much
without expectation like when people
hear that like a lot of people are
watching right now like [ __ ] [ __ ]
like the amount of money creation I've
made with my free advice at scale with
zero like bro do you understand there's
people that have made hundreds then
thousands then tens of thousands and
hundreds of thousands and millions who
are literally watching right now and are
not willing to buy $720 or the wine for
me it's crazy it's crazy it's it's
something that one has to wrap their
head around if you're going for legacy
it actually fundamentally doesn't bother
me I'm just trying to figure out how
here's my big thing that's one thing if
you made like five hundred thousand or
fifty thousand more because of my free
advice what I love for you to buy
empathy wines calm like a three pack a
three case pack for seven twenty of
course right bigger one that brain [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of me is the thousand
people that are watching right now who
actually will go to a local liquor store
or supermarket and buy twenty dollar
wine cuz they drink one like it's the
same thing with the sneakers right like
here's my thing yeah like if you wear
sneakers and you buy sneakers for 90 to
100 bucks I want you to buy my case with
it don't I don't keep concerning the
free stuff like if you buy 36 bottles of
wine a year in the 15 to 25 dollar range
I kind of want you to buy my wine like
are you really valuing going to
Albertsons or Costco or Bevo or binney's
or total wine like who the [ __ ] wants to
go to a store just order it I'm [ __ ]
empathy wines calm and let it be
delivered to you right right well and
you know and the point is to is what
kind of value have they got from you
over the last two years or however long
they've been you know one here's the
biggest key the reason this whole thing
works for me is for all the people that
are watching
I actually don't expect it yes
five now for four hours Nate how many
children salt what's your gut tell you
150 cases for four hours is like a joke
I've 25,000 to sell I get it I get it
so let me ask you this one last question
I know you're on speed around so one
last question am I better off trying to
if I'm gonna pay ten grand you know
before the end of the month am I better
off doing a barter and getting 10 grand
with the wine even if I a hot bro no how
do I do it for the few you go to empathy
wines cops go to Google email me na te
at empathy wines calm he'll hand hold
you like this five minutes where I'm
trading $10,000 worth of wine for a free
seat of four DS is like the greatest
deal ever like poor Nick is like putting
on his coat cuz he's leaving now cuz
he's like [ __ ] I just lost ten thousand
dollars in my P&L this [ __ ] Nate
just got it in his a my big thing with
you and everybody else who's watching is
if you go to the barter page and you try
to make a trade if we say yes you get an
asset like right 240 240 what is that
like 40 cases yeah dude you're gonna get
42 cases of wine here's my thing you can
either pay ten thousand dollars to come
for four days and get nothing or you can
buy yeah
or you can get 42 cases of wine and get
four DS for free and then you as a
businessman entrepreneur might be able
to use those 42 cases as surprise and
delight throw a party donated to a
charity like it's an asset of course you
should go through barter
now the here's the fun thing there's
only five thousand six thousand people
watching right now that even know about
this barter opportunity right so so I
need to email Nate at empathy wise calm
and say hey I want to do the barter
he'll hook you up with Nick and you'll
buy ten thousand dollars worth of wine
they'll ship it to you and you'll get
the four DS ticket for free like it's
[ __ ] smart even if you give it to
your [ __ ] neighbors be popular in
town yeah absolutely I know it was like
this sneaker deal that I missed out on
the bottle I don't give a [ __ ] ya know
it just makes sense it just makes sense
when I miss out on this week or
something that you get nothing with or
by the same thing that gives you 42
[ __ ] cases of wine I know this but
the red wine will last for 20 years put
in your [ __ ] basement survey and
[ __ ] daughter's Bar Mitzvah or
wedding or I don't [ __ ] know shoot
[ __ ] man I'm a grand I'm gonna grandpa
I'm a grandpa I got five grandkids toast
I'll serve it at my granddaughter's
wedding you're right dude you sound like
you're 23 you [ __ ] broke my face just
now I got five grandkids myth I'm 58
you sound 12 never when we're talking
when we were talking in that group my
dad is he was working at my dad's 85
years old he's still working hard every
day bro one I do remember one of the
things you can do back to what I
remember you can run some really smart
contests for free cases of wine oh [ __ ]
mm-hmm oh [ __ ] okay no I totally I am
totally naive can I ship wine it's a
little tricky but mate shaking his head
but honestly the government cares less
about humans than they care about
businesses you know okay you're where
again where's it was uh North Dakota
where are you again
I'm in Arizona Arizona dude honestly
like dude there's so much you can
[ __ ] do I'll figure it out I know you
all figured out dude it's of no lost
proposition you either buy a 4ds ticket
and get nothing or you buy four DS
ticket and get 42 [ __ ] cases of wine
holy [ __ ] that that's a no-brainer right
just like like when you get it shipped
like like literally take a case to the
public library and be like here
oh yeah no I got I got all kinds of
things I can do with it yeah no doubt
it's an asset oh absolutely yeah yeah i
dude it's almost one o'clock in the
morning
funk I'm doing right I know I know
you're tired [ __ ] man I'm [ __ ] too
pumped up I'm gonna go to sleep at 3:30
cuz I'm high as a [ __ ] kite
well Gary see ya thank you again so much
for all you do man I love you love you
alright everybody was watching there's
probably 20 or 30 of you Nate with my
admins Alex your [ __ ] beast like [ __ ]
Tyler like like we will we will reach
out to you we will send a bulk email to
all of you
once Tyler Alex Nate come together we'll
probably allocate two hours in the next
thirty days and we'll call all of you
thank you everybody who's watching I'm
about to go in the car go home please
hit me up on Twitter Gary Vee with your
hot take your two cents on tonight it
was clearly epic night number two people
are watching tonight if at bare minimum
nine bottles you've heard it tonight
which this whole entire marathon sold
150 cases I need to sell 25,000 I'm a
deep [ __ ] so if you can find it in your
heart if you can afford it don't extend
yourself but if you can afford it if you
buy wine if you have gifts if you have
clients if you have a business if you're
the lobby in your office they can put it
in if you want to do a happy hour for
your clients or employees like if you're
thinking about buying gifts in December
for clients like it would mean the world
to me if you could buy a nine bottle
subscript which is three bottles of each
three bottle subscription eighteen
bottle six bottles of Christian and the
ultimate the club empathy which gives
you Nora and the rest of team as a
sommelier for you on text the club
empathy 720 all in I'm gonna leave you
with this last right hook if you're
still watching and I see about 5,000 of
you right now
empathy wines calm like it would mean
the world to me if me texted me in seven
minutes and said [ __ ] we got a flood of
orders three pack subscriptions six pack
subscriptions cases students actually
matter the most I'm slurring I'm
finished but it would really really mean
a lot to me if there's anything
a value that I've given it really really
[ __ ] matters I don't know us to say
so what is it a three pack subscription
is all-in at 81 no to 42 43
you only get billed 81 tonight 243 and
all-in and if you want the Rose a that I
[ __ ] flip for tonight we're gonna be
offering it as um you can buy them for
the count on it thank you so much thank
you the dude yes me people are asking if
they can give a subscription to clients
when they order is there a note as a
like a note card okay real quick if you
emailed Nate or Noora Noora UNRRA if you
email Nate or Nora or John Jo Ann at
empathy wines calmly say one more time
John
Nora Nate when you order a subscription
if you put in the person that you're
shipping to address and you want to
email them a note that you want to put
in there and let's send up loose
effusion and get that feature in and be
means the world to me I would love your
support it would matter a lot to me if I
made texted me in 15 minutes and said
holy [ __ ] we just got a flood of orders
three pack subscriptions
only eighty one dollars bill tonight 240
for the year as they come out that's why
I asked thank you so much and if you
want to do something crazy it's Google
empathy wines barter because I think
it's empathy wines calm slash there's a
tab on border a barter barter we're
looking for yeah do you rocket I ran it
but I [ __ ] drink a bottle of wine what
do you want from me see I love you yes
you saw the preview 200 for us tonight
if you were here I know it's cool see
you
that was [ __ ]